e
e e
all right good morning it's um it's 2
minutes after 10 and um had a nice
little sidebar conversation there with
Mr White and I think we're we're ready
to get going um I call uh division 3
work session uh in order and we are
going to today uh hear from the veterans
home and we're going to hear from the
new later at 10:30 the New Hampshire
hospital Glen Cliff home Hamstead
hospital so today is
basically uh chairman Edwards I'm sorry
yeah we have a question over here
do do you want to interrupt my great
introduction because no no go ahead I
must have been boring you go go ahead
what finish I just I wanted to be sure
you saw me okay so uh so today is uh
direct uh care day and uh a lot of
people talk about
priorities uh you know families are
priorities children are priorities
pregnant women are priorities refugees
are priorities we have a ton of
priorities ities but I I personally
think we can't have any higher priority
than uh taking care of the patients that
are that we are directly responsible for
that we have care providers doing the
handson care to me uh that's kind of the
first order um so uh so I'm a little
biased about today uh I have some
general questions I'm going to ask but
um uh but other than that I I I I that
that's my context for today uh rep
representative walner yes thank you and
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt you I
just wanted to be sure that you that you
saw that I had my hand up um there's a
couple of things that I've been
wondering about the first one is last
week on the house floor we uh had the
revenue estimates from the house Ways
and Means Committee and then we put them
on the table those are usually what the
uh finance committee has to work with
and I think probably everybody here
knows that they're about $500
million less than what was in the
governor's uh proposed budget and I
wondered I know that some of the other
divisions one of the other divisions at
least has seemed to be working on a
Target I don't know what their target is
but they seem to know what they're where
they're going and I'm wondering if you
have any information for us about this
Division and what we'll be looking at as
far as future work on the budget and
possible reductions in um in
Appropriations that is a really great
question one that I'm not prepared to
answer at the moment but before the end
of the day I'll answer it great thank
you I appreciate that I have just one
more okay I think I heard you yesterday
on um say that on Monday we're going to
be working on
bills and um do we know how many bills
we have coming to this Division and this
will be division work or when we say we
I I think you mean the Royal we and that
includes uh Mr
Ripple oh yes Mr Ripple of course so
I'll actually need to check with Janet
and see how many bills have been
assigned to uh division 3 so I'll see if
I can get you a number
okay you have another Well I just wanted
to follow up with that one
um what will the process be and how much
time do you think you'll allow for each
bill I haven't looked at them yet I just
sort of did a mental note as we went
through in the house on Thursday you
know bills that had FNS that seemed like
it could hit us um it felt to me like
there were three or four okay um I I I
thought what we would need to do is um
spend about an hour hour on each okay
and then uh anticipate needing to um a
soak time give us each some time to look
at it independently and come back on a
second day to do um a recommendation for
the full finance committee so I was
thinking two bites of the apple one to
Tee It Up give everyone some time to
think and then a second day to uh get an
assessment from the division three what
we should tell the finance committee
okay one other question will they be
listed in the calendar um sometimes
people are confused about what the the
process is in the finance committee once
the bill comes over here my Mike I know
uh my my goal uh and I think Mr ripples
on top of it is is we're going to be
able to get it into the calendar with
the bills that we're going to look at on
Monday okay great thank you very much I
appreciate it and representative Mooney
and I have talked about how we had made
an attempt to get a policy person here
for
71 and um I I and we've decided that
we're going to escalate our directness
and our our uh request to to make it
more clear that they really need to be
here good I think that'd be really
helpful so representative Mooney thank
you for that I just wanted to make
mention that yes I want to push for that
in that the sponsors or members of the
policy Committee of these bills should
really be appearing in front of the
divisions when they're referred to so I
will do my best to uh notify these
individuals but if any of you know
sponsors or co-sponsors or policy
committee members please notify them as
well as to when the hearing will be in
division three thank
you so Mr Ripple there's there's uh two
two questions for you one you're ready
to answer but the other is uh are the
bills that we think we're going to talk
about Monday are we going to be able to
list them in the house
calendar so yes uh so you have three
bills House Bill 704 751 and 54 and
they'll get in the calendar that comes
out Thursday afternoon Friday morning so
yes they'll appear in the
calendar thank you any other questions
representative
walner you good no I think that's about
it for me just right now thank you okay
and I owe you a a proper answer
representative priest yes I have a
couple questions those were 701 704 and
54 uh
704 751 okay and 54 great um then I have
a a inform not information but a
clarification and maybe Mr Whipple can
answer maybe you can answer but when I'm
going through the uh the budget the
governor's budget and I see the funding
source and it's let's say it's the
educational fund to one of these
divisions and it's like three million
and so I'm wondering if what's the
policy for that to take money from a
fund that is supposed to be earmarked
for public education and it's going to
another
department you're asking a question I
don't know the answer to because I don't
I'm not in division 2 and so I'm not
familiar with the the policies around
protecting the educational trust fund I
I don't know uh so what I'd like to do
though is I'd like to because they only
had 30 minutes the veteran home go ahead
because we should finish them at 10:30
i' I'd like to get that going and then
we've got uh three uh care providers up
after that so so if you if if we haven't
figured out how to answer your question
representative priest let's let's do it
after we get through
these all right so uh I think we have
the commandant of the veterans home
ready to come up
and your your your budget
agitant good morning for the record I'm
Kim McKay I'm the commod at the New
Hampshire veterans home we did provide
you with a PowerPoint presentation that
we'll go through um but as always you
can stop me at any time I love to brag
about the veterans home so sometimes I
get a little uh passionate about it so
um Can Can I can I give you a clue to
help guide your testimony uh because we
basically have uh 18 minutes I'm going
to be fast so so what we're really
looking for is is are your big rocks the
things the things that you're that are
influencing your ability to care for X
number of
people how many people are waiting
Services what do we need to get do to
get those people Services just really
kind of a strategic uh look down into
your operations okay I I hear you so
I'll skip the where are we who are we um
just besides saying that we're a
long-term care intermediate facility uh
we only serve veterans that were e
either on their DD214 left for service
out of New Hampshire or reside in New
Hampshire um we are licensed for 250
beds we are budgeted with currently for
225 veterans um and we utilize the
Veterans Affair uh Affairs grant program
enabled under uh 38 CFR 5141 and that
allows us to have reimbursement on a
daily uh prum amount for our residents
to share the cost of them being there um
I our mission statement just I want to
just do want to say that is to provide
the best quality for the life of the New
Hampshire veteran with dignity honor and
respect um some of our achievements I
will kind of just leave this here in the
PowerPoint presentation we've created an
LNA program to try to combat our biggest
issue is Staffing um and we were working
on trying to cut energy cost saving some
of those uh monies with uh a project
that was placed to replace lighting and
we have been able to um provide Wi-Fi
now for our residents but I want to do
want to say that uh our wait list was
sometimes over a year and uh we have
seen a huge um decrease in that because
we've invested the the staff in those
areas so our admission weight list
process is now 3 to 6 months which is
really a great
achievement all right so I'm going to go
on what we have right now so right now
we have 135 veterans in the home today
and we have another four Veterans
schedule to come in we still have about
after that 36 uh people that are in
application process so our goal is to
get our census in in the next um
probably by in two two months or so we
want to move to about 150 with our
current staff we think we can meet the
needs of the veterans uh at 150 veterans
with our current staff the long-term
goal is to fill our positions that we
have so that we can go to that 225 preco
era um and have the needs do we think we
can fill the beds that's what I'm always
asked are you going to be able to fill
the beds I believe we will be able to
fill the beds because if we added our
weight list in our current census we
would be in that 100 high 170 Mark I
think what happens in the community we
have to do a little bit of that PR is to
let people know that it's not a year
plus or 2year wait to get into the
facility that were able to move people
in much quicker and so those veterans
that are home or in a crisis and they
need placement right away they don't go
to a a a different nursing home and then
have to be transferred over that's
Staffing so we have some new people on
the division since last budget and I
just want to acknowledge uh two really
big things that have uh happened in in
in the last two years um one the the
wait time to from an application to
actually be admitted is is incredibly
good relative to the how long it had
been so congratulations and thank you
and and also appreciate you having a
manageable uh weit list of people who
are who are getting in that's that
that's great progress in two years I'm
looking forward to see what it is in two
more years the second thing is you guys
had been struggling to create a separate
Wi-Fi network for your residents and
that was causing all kinds of issues and
it's sounds like you've got that now and
that it's really uh been embraced and is
really valuable to the social networking
and the and that sa life satisfaction of
your resident so so I right away those
are two really great things thank you
sir thank you thank you uh we did Wi-Fi
uh we know that being connected to your
family helps quality of life and um I
jokingly say when when we say at a
meeting to please silence your cell
phones I have to say that during
meetings some times because the veteran
cell phones are going off all the time
they're really connected to their
families and that Wi-Fi project was also
not just want getting the Wi-Fi but it
was also updating our conference room so
that if a loved one can't travel in the
winter for a care plan meeting where
we're going to discuss what their spouse
is getting for care they can actually
zoom in or teams call in and they can be
in the meeting with us so that this week
and last week were those Technologies
were being put in our conference rooms
so we're excited about that thank you
for that
acknowledgement um again uh we our
biggest um hurdle is Staffing and we're
trying really hard to uh continue with
advertising uh going to anything we can
speak at being part of college uh fairs
signing up for things like handshake um
anything that's available to us one of
the pieces that I did put in this year
is that we have a learning management
system that's going to be electronic
so that people can take take their
mandatory trainings that they have to do
every long-term care has to do Resident
rights we must do abuse and neglect
training we've never had ability to give
uh ex continuous education units CEUs to
our medical staff our nursing staff we
now are going to have that ability to
provide cus that doesn't sound like a
big recruitment um uh tag but it is to
be able to say to a nurse or an LNA or a
physical therapist you can come on our
team you're going to do your mandatory
trainings that we all have to do but
you're going to be able to have free cus
it's a very small investment for us to
uh ensure education's happening but also
to promote that so so I understand
you're outside um you're not part of the
Department of Health and Human Services
no sir we stand so the other Direct Care
uh providers like the New Hampshire
hospital you you don't necessarily have
a direct relationship with them you
probably have a professional one I
assume I to what extent have you been
able to cooperate with each other to
leverage professional uh training
programs like I'm sure uh the department
has a learning management system I don't
know if you have a learning management
that's where we're get we are now going
to be putting into place yes are are you
getting it on your own are you going
through the department of it to get it
we're getting it with o doit they they
had to uh check this as well and it's
really focused on it's called Healthcare
Academy and it's um focused on the
things that have to happen in long-term
care those kind of focuses that we have
so I would assume a good deal of overlap
on the kinds of professional training
and CME that you you all need has got to
be pretty similar to the New Hampshire
hospital it would be nice if you guys
could have some some coffee talk someday
to figure out how you how you can help
each other that sounds great good point
okay representing wner did you have a
question earlier I found the answer all
right thank you okay
representative novano just a very quick
question for my my understanding is the
vacancy rate start I mean sorry the lit
time starts at the approval um no it
starts the day we start counting you the
day that you actually put your first
application in so in the past the
application process is so multi-layered
you would need to get information from
the family you would need to get bank
account information for the VA we need
to get medical records so if you see a
primary care physician in three
specialists we had to get records from
all of them but there wasn't enough
staff in our admissions Department to
really help push that through so
sometimes they would linger and now
we're able to say to the family let us
help let us call and get some of that
information and that's really what
shortened up the time so when we say the
wait list it it's really from the start
okay so it's a actually so you can't
admit somebody until all the paperwork
there's a lot so the the real weit time
is actually even better than 3 to six
months if you could you know which
shorten if you could speed up the the
paperwork yes I I I I hear the number as
from the veterans point of view from the
day I drop a completed packet it's going
to be three months before I have a bed
that and that and that's and that's the
waiting period that matters is what what
it feels like to the veteran but is that
is that what the three to six months is
3 to 6 months depending from the day
they put their application in and to
that we are offering them a bed we're
offering beds so quickly now that some
families were still under the mindset
they were have a year or two before they
had to make a decision that they're
saying thank you for approving me but
we're not quite ready can you give us
two months and so it's interesting that
we're we're at that point and sometimes
we get people who uh apply that is 80
they're 85 years old they're hike we
just had a gentleman 85 years old still
hiking three miles a day with his dog uh
drives does all of his own things but
the age sounds like he should be with us
but's not ready for us he doesn't meet
long-term care requirements so yeah
representative priest and representative
Stringham thank you Mr chairman and
thank you uh Miss McKay for your service
thank you and for all you do um question
uh do you have the same coordination
with the nonprofit organizations that
provides housing for Veterans so if they
have a client that's Health it's
declining do they notify you and help
the client to process the necessary
paperwork to get a hospital bed yes sir
so we have uh many ways that people are
referred into us from the VA working
with the veterans and having social
workers at the seox or even the main
campus we have people in the community
that will make referrals church people
who will have someone in their Parish
who needs to have some support uh
neighbors most commonly families um but
they come in different ways so uh our
RSA wise anybody who is homeless is
going to take an advanced stand on our
weight list our weight list is not like
a deli number where I I'm Number One
You're Number Two you're number three we
don't do it that way we look at it from
our RSA standpoint of your risk what is
your risk if you're living at home or
homeless um and you don't have support
staff that's much different than
somebody who is in another nursing home
wanting to transfer into us so we look
at all of those pieces and when somebody
comes to us that is a homeless vet they
take a higher higher uh stance on our
wait list thank you you're welcome pres
string I I think you answered this
question later on but I was going to ask
about the churn meaning how many uh
people are leaving uh the Veteran's
nursing home and uh on a regular basis
and the veterans themselves yeah um so
most often our veterans pass we have an
average age of 83 which means um we have
a lot of people in their 90s we have one
gentleman who is 100 um one of we we age
from 61 years is our youngest 100 is our
oldest and so we normally see about 45
um people pass a year so we have a lot
of people coming in and a lot of people
going out the average time that they
spend with us is about 2 and 1/2 years
and that's average some people come to
us um at the very end of their time and
then some people people will live with
us for five or six years um so a lot of
people come and go uh very few are
discharged but we do have some success
stories where they got better they were
able to go back out into the community
and that's been great too and uh follow
followup um so it it looks like most of
the current was weight list is
applications in process do you have
adequate staff to process four to five
applications per month yes that's why
we're seeing a weight list from a year
to two down to 3 to six months I'm very
proud of them they're doing a great
job all right um on slide 10 we just
talk about the census and you can see
that covid really affected the veterans
home and we're slowly creeping that up
the slide that we were just talking
about on 11 is the discharges and so
when we say discharges that usually
means they've
passed military branch always put that
in there because there's a lot of
competition it doesn't matter uh what
branch you served in they all like each
other but they're going to ask where you
served and uh and if you're a marine
you're going to take it a little tougher
because uh but they say they can handle
it so we we let that go um and then we
do a conflict era we're seeing a lot of
our uh World War II veterans pass um
it's sad to see that um and we are we
still have one um we have one Gulf War
and I I'm assuming that we'll start
seeing that uh increase but the more
larger majority is our Vietnam veterans
that are with us right
now the vacancy moving to what we are
talking about for Staffing our vacancy
rate still is overall about
35% um now some of that it can be
misleading because I'm purposely holding
some of those positions because we're
not at a census at 225 so I think it's
not I think it's fiscally responsible to
the taxpayers to say don't fill
positions just to fill them because you
have them unless you have the census of
the veteran and those are only in areas
like um extra housekeepers cuz we have
neighborhoods that are closed um some
laundry workers because we don't have
that laundry the one thing that we will
never close down on recruitment is
nursing and lnas those are our those
people are the ones that drive our
census for our veterans the more nurses
and lnas you have the more veterans we
can have and so we we will always be
recruiting for them um and how do we do
that I was uh having a conversation
prior to this I believe that it's not
really a recruitment issue that we have
with the state of New Hampshire and it's
not unique to me it's a how do we retain
people how do we keep them in state
service because we can hire them they
come on but when we do exit interviews
we are it's very clear that people are
leaving for higher pay bonuses different
hours um and some are leaving without
benefits they're signing up for
temporary um the contracted nurses and
doing contracted work because they're
getting paid so much more if I'm a if
I'm a laundry worker in a a health care
facility such as myself and some of the
DHHS sites we're handling laundry that
is contaminated and so if we're getting
paid 13 or $14 an hour then and I can go
to a hotel and make a lot more money and
not contain handle that contamination or
or I'm in McDonald's and I'm making $16
an hour and I'm making a cheeseburger
cheeseburger a burger with no cheese
much different than making a prior diet
knowing the allergies of our residents
the likes and dislikes it's much more
serious and so we're seeing people leave
for those reasons so it's a retention
issue as much as a a recruitment
issue go go ahead thank you Mr chairman
what is the tenure usually for your
nursing staff how many years do they
kind of stay with you before they um get
a better offer it's difficult to say
because we have some nurses that have uh
been with us for 20 plus years many 10
um we do longevity through the state and
I give longevity Awards out every
quarter many many nurses the ones that
we see in come are the ones that are
usually younger um are going to other uh
positions uh lnas when we have lnas come
they're they're they're moving when
they're younger they're moving to other
places with bonuses and sign-ons and um
can I get 12 hours can I only can I get
paid for 40 hours and only work 32
there's a lot of creative things that
the private sector can do that we can't
as a state and every time we we increase
the wages for our staff the private
sector is much more uh fluid and can
change their wages really quickly so we
got wage increases that brought us to
even with everybody but as soon as we
did that all they had to do is increase
the wages a little bit more and we don't
have that a fluid or that ability to do
that thank
you quick question I want I want to jump
ahead oh go ahead represent do you have
any contract nurses now we do sir yes um
we we have uh a handful of them and
they're both basically focused on that
second shift we have people that work
third shift if you're a third shift
person and you're a night owl you're
usually a third shift person and first
shift is easy to fill where we feel the
biggest pain for us is on that second
shift and so we do have second shift uh
contracted
nurses uh do regular staff who take the
second shift get um added payment second
shift for nurses is an additional $4 an
hour um but for lnas it is not they're
not treated in the same way so it's $160
an hour for lnas um one of our one of
hopefully we'll see move is to match the
lna's licensed nursing assistance to the
same payscale um or shift differential
that nurses experience because it's $7
on third shift it's $4 on second that's
a lot of money that what you're looking
at your salary are those percentages
though they they end up as dollar
amounts but did they start as
percentages no they're straight dollar
amounts that they've been negotiated
through the contract the the Union Yes
okay can can we jump to P 19 we can
um did did you did you go ahead what's
your question good question yeah quick
question it's a follow on to
representative stringham's question so
the 30 uh the you know between about 40%
average U of vacancies so part of that
is covered by contract nurses and and I
guess overtime or yes yes sir overtime
because that's a fairly big gap and I
was just wondering how
well we I also don't fill the census to
the where so the census I don't have 225
residents so I match the census of
veterans to the vacancy rate so that I
we're providing the quality of care so
we don't we're not running at 225
Veterans as
well okay so if you if you went to the
150 you you'd have to cover more with
contract Andor nope we're going to cover
it with the current staff we have so
we're on Monday we're changing the way
we have some of our neighborhoods to uh
to add more uh the staff with the same
same staff will be able to do more
because we're reconfiguring some of our
neighborhoods so we're going to be able
to go safely with this number of staff
to 150 150 residents um and we do that
with uh something called PPD patient per
day hours so how many hours a patient
gets a day we really look at those
formulas so we're making that decision
of how far we can go with a very uh
objective tool to make that happen so I
just want to commend you for uh the
creativity and doing more with less
thank you
sir okay so on 19 U this this is this
appears to be your whole budget request
and it's probably a page in the budget
are you able to tell us what page this
is on do you have the page numb
Y for the record Jennifer do CFO of the
veterans home um this is just a rolled
up summary page of our entire budget I I
know but can you tell me what page
number one uh
1,65
two I'm trying to get the
end that's all right it looks like 170
170 70 okay so I I I want to ask you
about your prescription drug expenses
yes sir uh and the management of those
are you are you on your own are you on
an island uh negotiating and getting
your prescription drug prices or or are
you part of uh the VA system and then
they just back bill you for what you use
how do how how's your how's that work
okay so we have a we have a a pharmacy
contract um and so we contract out our
Pharmacy Services they're on site but
they're a contract they're not
state-owned we do have reimbursements
through through the VA depending on the
person's disability and um and the
medication so we can build the VA for a
medication that's associated with the
disability that they have and we do that
so we have about um right now I would
say $30,000 comes back each month on the
pharmaceutical cost from the VA the rest
is on us and we have a formulary that we
follow for the VA so that's how we
actually do it is through the VA so so
if if you were just to boil it all down
um you you don't have any control over
the pricing and you don't have any
control over the volume because the
volume is driven by what the Physicians
prescribe right true so so you're
basically just a pass through entity on
this line item for things that you can't
control true and we oh sorry I so so so
is there any
with the new Administration are they
talking or have you beg to hear anything
about what they might be doing to um
help Control prescription drugs because
this is pretty big jump from year to
year right right so one of the things
that we are working on right now is
something called catastrophic disability
applications and so the VA is taking
applications for people who live in the
uh in the state veterans homes and if
they qualify for catastrophic disability
which we have seen some of them all of
their medications will be covered from
the VA so we are seeing we I we
anticipate that we will see this line
have a lot of money at the end but we
are not positive um about
that um yes so there's also some large
cost medication uh bills that are
underway uh Congressman uh papis has
signed on and he is going to be bringing
a bill forward through the National
Association of State veterans homes for
high cost medications example we have a
medication right now that one veteran is
on and it's $5,000 a month for that one
medication and so we have asked if they
that veteran was in a nursing home in
the community the VA would pay for that
medication but because we get VA per DM
rates from the VA we have always been
exempt from actually getting those money
those monies reimbursed to us so we have
brought that forward to the house and
the US H the US CER uh the US House is
going to be bringing a u Bill forward
asking for an exemption for high cost
medications and that the VA the Veterans
Home can build a VA for those
medications that we have always been
exempt from so we're hoping this line
does not need to be this High yeah but
at this point we're projecting what we
are based on what we have right now and
projecting on a
225 census if we had 225 veterans this
is what we're projecting so you're
basing your prescription drugs based on
a full 22
so this is probably overstated by quite
a lot 4% we hope so but we also don't
want to um hinder ourselves by not doing
being able to do admissions based on not
having enough money and are these
General funds here these are all General
funds right or go ahead so so I guess
the federal government does give us some
money for that it's roughly 24% and 76%
General funds 76% General funds okay um
I'll come to you in a second and and I
think you have um a fourth Revenue
stream that we were talking about
beforehand where there's uh you all
because so many supporters for there are
for veterans that you guys have sort of
a off the books um account system where
you can receive donations yes let me
speak to that because it's not and and
the state oversees that whole thing so
all the you know fraud waste abuse
issues are managed yes sir but that
money stays off the books until you need
to transfer it over into the state
system to um to to to buy something
whether you use a a purchasing card or
contract it's got to come over so that
you can spend it through the state
facilities right yes so and from your
own fund you don't do any direct
purchasing at all it all goes through
State systems right so well we have two
dedicated funds one is called the
membership account and that's all of the
residents have check they have
individual Check accounts in that that's
through uh the a dedicated fund the
donation account you're talking about
it's not a revenue resource I just want
to make sure we the state doesn't use
that money to do anything um with not
the state but you but our benefit our
res you you do as a common this is
another asset class abely absolutely and
that's all donations that come from uh
people in the community veteran service
organizations example Christmas is we uh
asked people to sponsor Veterans for
$75 we can't use taxpayer dollars to buy
them Christmas gifts and so how do you
do that how do you provide for them how
do we pay for cable TV we don't use
taxpayer dollars to pay for cable TV we
use our benefit fund and that's all done
through the dedicated fund which is has
a lot of oversight um first from the
board of managers that overseas us
as well as we go to GNC to accept all
our donations we're very transparent
about where our money comes from and
where it goes so so the reason I'm
dwelling on this this is mostly for the
committee I think is because this idea
of having donation accounts set up for
other entities has come up um in other
places like we have an hb2 the
department wants to uh be able to
collect up to
$1,000 and I I just thought that the way
that the vet Veterans Home is doing this
may be a metaphor for some of these
other things and you don't have a
ceiling I think you told me that you had
one donation of $100,000 for example yes
yes right and sometimes higher we uh are
Beque money sometimes uh and sometimes
they the family may actually want you to
do something with it we recently had a
$10,000 donation where they wanted us to
put some improvements in our Physical
Therapy gym um and so if they ask us to
spend it in a certain way we will do
that if they don't then we use it for
General so so so for those following
Along on page 49 of
hb2 line 16 is a has an has a number 95
there that or 96 that talks about gifts
to the state and so I'm just I'm just
wondering if we already have a metaphor
here that we should be adopting and I I
I I don't like that thousand limit
that's online 20 so it seems like we can
change that number substantially as long
as we're consistent with what however
you're set up did you have a question
rep I representative n
Von very quick question what's the
typical balance in that fund it it's
none of our business in a way right
right I mean they don't I I mean I I I
don't want to pull words in our mouth
but but one of the beauties of that fund
is it's none of our business it's it's
it's it's money that are being provided
for the veterans it's under management
of the state to make sure no one's
stealing it and that it's being
transferred over and and um and if it's
not enough money they can go ask for
more money right so the only time we
touch the state with that is that we
have a line an accounting line that um
we will put in money so I think of it as
like a debit card if we're going to buy
Christmas gifts on um on our PE card we
need to put money from that account
that's the members or the benefit fund
and it goes into the state account so we
can have it flow through but that
account is has a lot of oversight and I
just want to say that we don't spend
that money without approval from our
Board of managers there's 12 members in
the community that are on that board of
managers every uh quarter we talk about
what we're going to spend and how we're
going to spend it and we're always
looking to I'm using you as an example
of of something that we may want to
leverage so representative priest
thank you Mr chairman um on your revenue
streams on page 18 uh on the VA
um with the current climate in
Washington where there's being Cuts made
and cuts were recently made in the
VA what reductions are you seeing that's
filtering down on your budget great
question so uh we always get a little
worried when we hear that there's any
kind of holds or um issues with the
budget we've been reassured that the
veterans uh State veterans homes are not
going to be affected that this money
will still flow through and we have had
a couple of times when the uh in the
past the government has kind of closed
stopped and um we still have gotten
payments so we don't see any worries
right now and we've been reassured as
much as we can on a regular basis that
this this funding source is going to be
there um in fact we're seeing an
increase of uh getting more VA funding
because we're able to uh with the packed
act uh sign people up for a higher
disability rating and so they get a
bigger um benefit to them and we get a
bigger uh PDM rate and you'll see in
number one when you look at the cost and
how we get if they're u under 70% we get
a one rate of $144 a day if they're over
70% we get 800 uh excuse me $587 so it's
a big significant difference and so we
think we'll see more funding not less
funding okay we're running short out
time um you guide me and I I think you
want to talk to us about uh page
20 yes do you want to talk about that go
ahead all
right we would love the ability to be
able to
transfer um between classes and to be
able to put money in the most effective
way to use for the veterans there are
some limitations in some of our County
units 47 48 um and others in in the
ability to transfer um we don't want to
go against uh going to fiscal or GNC for
that oversight we want to still do that
but just have the ability to so let me
throw a cynical case at you and tell me
how how this would work it sounds to me
like your prescription drug line might
be
inflated so if we pass this in hb2 would
that it set up an incentive for you to
inflate your prescription drug so you
can transfer it into other accounts
later we could so so so I'm a little
concerned about that um I I I think I
think I think the members need to read
this and we may need to get in touch
with you to talk about it some more
because I I I don't want to
create okay we work in healthc care and
so there's always some great thing that
everyone wants to fund in healthc care
it's sort of the Untouchable thing that
everyone wants to fund and so I don't I
don't want to create a an incentive in
the system to to Really fund the thing
that everyone is attracted to and then
have the money leak out to the other
places where it's it's needed so I I I I
don't want a lot of that but but you but
I I know that you need flexibility and I
so there's maybe a different way of
doing it but I just want to point out
this was language that was in there in
last the last budget we were we did not
have a budget manager we did not have a
CFO and that's how it fell out we didn't
so this has always been in this language
has always been in there it fell out
this last budget because I didn't know
um and the person that was trying to
fill in didn't know so this is why we're
asking for it to be put back in there
it's not new it's just something that we
didn't have the ability before so um
ethics are still there you still have to
be able to say why you want that money
in that line um but I hear what you're
saying there's a concern of over
inflation to be able to move this um so
we're we are again asking just sort to
have that restored so honestly I haven't
read this or thought about it so but but
but I will okay thank you representative
Stringham uh three questions um um the
other um uh parts of uh DHHS people who
present here division 3 uh have have
largely unfunded positions that were
open is anybody asked you to do the same
thing or sir so these POS so the budget
assumes that all those positions would
be filled yes sir and um last year you
spent about 34 million I think uh isn't
it a fair assumption on our part that
there'll probably be a considerable
lapse um in the forward budget of 50 to
52 million um when we get through the
next bium uh by the time we get there I
hope to fill all the positions but I I
can't I can't speak to to what will
happen I I mean our our goal is to keep
filling them and retain them and those
positions would be needed if you're at
full capacity but I can't go to it's
kind of a catch 22 I can't go to full
capacity until I have the staff to
provide the care so that's why we're
doing this when I first came on three
years ago we had a cap of 121 veterans
and that was where our staffing was
today we feel that we can go to 150
safely and meet the needs and still be
within the VA requirements and our
certification um so we are creeping
that's three years but uh going from 121
to 150 I think is a good growth and so
we just want to keep getting back to
where we were prior to co so if you were
at the full capacity I mean right now
you obviously don't have the wait list
for that do you think more people would
be applying absolutely okay thank you
absolutely um at the at at grafting
County um the numbers that we we uh came
up with uh converting a traveling nurse
to a full-time nurse is saving the
county about $50,000 per employee uh per
year uh going back from being a traveler
to a full-time in-house staff even with
salary adjustments do you think those
numbers if you know would be similar
here I think if we could fill our
positions we would save a lot more money
than paying for travelers Travelers are
very expensive they're only there for 13
weeks you have a lot of uh getting them
onboarded and so you're investing that
education but then they're gone in 13
weeks honestly uh most of them resign
with us so we are getting longer than 13
weeks um and some have actually switched
over to be full-time employees once they
come they fall in love with the veterans
and they stay um but we know that that
is not it's not sustainable it's not a
good way to spend and monies we need to
fill them with full-time positions but
we can fill them how do we keep them is
the is the question how do we keep the
healthc care engaged with the state of
New Hampshire at the
salaries so representative tki and then
representative priest super quick I'm
just wondering going back to page 20 if
Kevin could maybe do a little dive into
previous budgets to see where that
language dropped out and how long it had
been in
place I can do that I know it was in
place in the 2022 23 budget I'm not sure
how long prior to that it had uh been
there thanks and and then I'd like your
advice Mr Ripple if you if how we might
be able
to tighten this without messing up the
flexibility
but okay I can think about that
yeah uh representative priest um a
question along with the representative t
tris's uh question um are other
departments do they have this provision
already within this
flexibility um transferred funds and was
the veterans the only one that was
dropped in the last
budget no this transfer Authority would
be broader than what other departments
have in
statute I see thank you a a question uh
for you um Miss McKay are you
able to have a program for college um
tuition
forgiveness for nursing and l
lnps l LPN um to come and work for you
for like 10 years and have their college
tuitions forgiven if they did that we
don't have anything like that but I will
tell you that one of my um dreams would
be able to have and we just knew that we
couldn't put it in the state budget this
year is to sponsor and grow within so
right now we are growing lnas licensed
nursing assistants they may come um and
work in housekeeping or laundry and they
love working with the veterans and they
become lnas so we have an LNA program um
and they commit to a year and what we
can't do is create nurses so I would
love to see us invest in our staff and
say if you're an LPN and you want to
become an RN it's a one-year bridge
program if you want to be an if you're
an LNA and you want to be become an LPN
a one-year bridge program we invest that
$25,000 uh four times two LPNs to nurses
and full RNs and one uh two lnas to LPN
we would be investing and we I think it
could be a recruitment a retention you
ask them to stay um but it's just
something that we knew that we couldn't
put in the budget we were already asking
a fair amount for the budget but that
would be something that we'd love to see
so you're talking something aspirational
that's not in this budget not in this
budget um we already knew that we were
asking for quite a bit here um and so we
didn't feel like we could push it that
far all right we we've gone long I think
we've had some good uh questions and
answers um do you do you have I know I
rushed you and made you skip some pages
you have it so so before you go away if
there's something you wanted to say that
you've not yet said here's your chance
uh that the Veterans Home is a very
unique place it's a wonderful location a
a wonderful campus and if you're
available to come and meet our veterans
and know what we're doing we welcome you
anytime um it it is just the pride so so
it sounds like once a year at least if
not more frequently you have a kind of
an outdoor picnic kind of thing where
the the the supporting veterans
organizations host it we have a lot of
events so we have like I'm I'm I'm
begging for an invitation just send
inv come come we have ceremonies on a
regular basis I got to pick out my room
I got to go and pick out my room all
right all right we will be happy to send
you our list of Ceremonies and events
okay I'm wrapping up do you have
something yeah I do one quick question
and it builds on I think something that
rep representative priest asked and
partially representative Edwards
cooperation I I've recently I'm familiar
with a um an outside organization Harbor
care
and I think one of their big
priorities U that I attended a
fundraiser for is their focus one of
their focuses on uh homeless veterans
yes and they're I believe it's an agency
that's funded through
DHHS that and I'm wondering if there any
cooperation yes we have a relationship
with them as well with referrals I think
okay great glad to hear that okay well
thank you looking forward to having a
hot dog with your veterans we put it out
there okay all right thank you
thank and then uh it looks like New
Hampshire hospital is stage to come
next is are the people from Glen Cliffe
here raise your hand that was going to
be my question to you Mr chair do you
mind if Glen cliff goes first I I'm
flexible
okay and we're doing doing that because
they have the furthest to drive or
just thank you for letting us go yes we
have the furthest drive but also uh we
can uh basically say ditto of what uh
the comant just said because we we
provide similar Services just at
different
populations do do you have a a
PowerPoint or pretty coloring book here
it comes uh we
do oh and for the record my my name is
Lewis Todd Bickford but I go by Todd the
executive director of Glen Cliff hm
so while this is getting passed out
several of us were able to come uh take
advantage of your kind offer to let us
tour your facility and I came away and
pressed with its beauty and its
remoteness so so you have some
interesting challenges looking looking
forward to what you have to say
today thank thank you for that it is a
spectacular place um up in the mountains
um in our location is part of our
challenges
absolutely great uh good morning Nathan
white Chief Financial Officer with the
Department of Health and Human Services
in the governor's operating budget uh
Glen Cliff home begins on page 900
184 and then there is also a a u a
budget briefing book section it's it's
three pages for Glen Cliff home again
it's just for the accounting units that
are over a million dollars annually and
with that said I'll hand it over to
Todd thank you for having us um I will
try and be as short as possible as well
um the first you know is our our Mission
our division mission is to strive to
provide a continuous services to New
Hampshire's developmentally uh
developmentally disabled and mentally
ill population in a h likee atmosphere
with an emphasis on Independence dignity
and acceptance um so we are very similar
to the veterans home we just serve a
different
population um the next slide talks about
our RSA
135c and then our administrative rules
um
hm700 you know again uh we are a
certified CMS uh licensed nursing home
um so we have to meet all the
requirements that that that entails and
then we specialize in serving people
with mental illness and developmental
disabilities um it lists out all the
services we provide which is you know
typical for any uh nursing
home next slide shows where we fit into
the OR chart for
DHHS and how we relate with the finance
department in New Hampshire hospital
moving on some quick key accomplishments
um unlike the veterans home um we do um
strive to get people back out into the
community as much as possible um which
has been a cultural change over the last
10 to 15 years um so we are proud to say
that in the last 5 years we've had 50
residents discharged to uh other
placements of their choice um a number
of those are into Community placements
um we also as the comant mentioned
strive to grow our own uh we have an LNA
program and an m& program an m& is an
LNA that has taken additional training
and and can help nurses pass medications
so we have had huge success with that
and right now we have four lnas um
enrolled uh so that'll help and then the
last accomplishment we listed here is
that um continuing to improve our
infrastructure um we have um you know
started replacing our Waste Water System
um for those those of you that haven't
had the opportunity to come up we are
completely off the grid um so there's a
lot of infrastructure
there next uh slide kind of gets into
the more we have a question very quick
I'm I'm impressed by your um nursing um
training program that you have going are
most of those people um locals to the
area that's great yes yes um and a lot
of family members um I believe right now
three of the four students we have are
related to other employees so it's a we
try and grow it that way as well great
thanks representative priest thank you
Mr chairman um when I was up there
visiting your campus and and uh thank
you for everything that you do and for
um providing uh a hospital facility for
these people uh two questions you don't
receive any
Medicaid uh
funding we we do you do okay yes 99% of
our uh population are all Medicaid um
residents okay okay and then second
while I was up there I kept hearing that
WiFi is a big
deterrent for your staff up there yes
and is there any plans are there any
plans uh to address this we we have
struggled with this for years um it took
Co to have any type of Wi-Fi but it is
uh pre limited um we're still basically
using DSL for the resident access um we
just this week are having starlink
installed um as a backup system for um
for the state system uh once that's
installed and we see that it actually
works as well as adverti we are going to
get a starlink system just for the
residents to have Wi-Fi um which is a
huge demand you know as quote unquote
younger folks come in over the last 20
years they come with phone and and
tablets and and laptops and um are
usually very distressed when there's a
huge lag that they can't um communicate
with their loved ones or watch the shows
and things that they want to do so yes
we we are hoping that'll be solved
shortly I think you can continue uh the
next slide is um our sensus information
um you'll see a a fairly significant
change when it comes to fiscal year 23
so um at the end uh to explain that in
the end of fiscal year 22 we chose to
freeze admissions uh due to Staffing uh
right now and we have for a number of
years now have about a 50 52% vacancy
when it comes to uh nurses and lnas so
to be able to safely maintain the
population we um capped ourselves at
75 um and while we were doing that then
the uh Governor sonunu uh decided uh as
part of the C uh CMHA the um Center uh
Community Mental Health agreement uh to
keep that cap in place to the end of
that uh agreement um and uh till we can
hire more staff um and that's why the
numbers have gone
down are are you going to get to the a
slide that talks about um your weight
list uh I don't have a specific slide
but I can answer any questions yeah yeah
so so give us if you wouldn't mind a um
a sense of of a couple of things um you
you are trying to um um discharge
patients out into various Community
Alternatives correct um you do have some
number of people that I assume you have
good visibility over that want that need
to be admitted to Glen Cliffe uh I I'm
just curious uh how big a population
that is and and what they're doing for
services until you get admitted they get
admitted because you you provide such a
unique environment I I I can't
imagine those Services being available
to an individual in the
wild um you're correct so um at the
moment we have 19 people on our waight
list um a a lot majority of folks come
from New Hampshire hospital in other
hospitals so they're being maintained in
a safe place while they wait to come to
us um we do um also get applications
from other nursing homes um they've
admitted somebody and that now has um
behaviors or um diagnosis that they
can't um help uh them with so they'll
refer them to us but again they're in a
safe place similar to the veterans home
if there is a homeless person that uh
has uh an application in uh they get
priority uh to come in we get a uh Fair
number uh in the last few years of
referrals from Doc um from Corrections
either individuals that have um finished
their uh term and uh can't find
placement anywhere else um or somebody
that has become um medically um
discharged basically from docc uh so we
have a large number of those folks that
other nursing homes aren't able to or
interested in providing services to so
all the people on our weight list are in
a safe place uh like I said if there is
a homeless person we will um move them
to the top of the list we recently just
had a um for example an individual that
came from docc who had finished his term
they contacted us about weeks before his
end date and they basically said you
need to take him or he's going on the
curb um they didn't really say that but
that was kind of the intention so um we
moved him to the top of the list we we
moved as fast as we could and we got him
um uh admitted um two weeks ago so um so
it's a great question um you know we get
a people from a variety of places uh and
we do serve a unique um
population we also uh you know part of
our sense of staying kind of stagnant
where it is is due to moving people out
into the community um the department has
uh had an RFP last vium um with NFI to
create um group homes um per se and
those have come online um so this year
we've been able to discharge um 11
people back into the community um we
also then have what's 11 like is that 11
significantly higher than previous years
yes significantly if you if you look
back 10 years maybe we would discharge
one person to the community and now
we're we're you know doing between you
know 8 and 12 a year okay um is what
we've been averaging and part of that is
the system itself amping and having more
um placement availability so so for the
people who are looking at this for the
first time I I I think one of the
challenges we have um with your
inability to have a higher census number
is there are institutions like the New
Hampshire hospital that we're going to
hear about that are also having some
some overflow problems and weightless
problems and they can't free their beds
until they have a bed to move some of
their patients to and if you're one of
those people and you can't handle them
then then that's that's where we're
finding uh blocks in our our patient
flow correct correct and we and we do
give priority other than the homeless
folks we do give priority to uh
residents that are patients that are at
New Hampshire hospital um but they have
to be clinically stable enough um
obviously the hospital is an acute
setting um so if there's somebody that
isn't quite safe enough in their
behavior for themselves or to our other
um residents then you know they might
need to stay at New Hampshire hospital a
little bit longer but we work extremely
um tightly with New Hampshire hospital
um uh to look at what what can we meet
their needs um and what's safe for
everybody else but yes that we are a a
backdoor solution for New Hampshire
hospital I I I think I interrupted you
on Page Six if you want to pick
up um I think we may have covered it all
I just wanted to explain why there was
the dip insid of census um you know as I
mentioned in the last uh 12 months we
had 11 discharges back to the community
we also had um seven residents um uh
pass um so that's kind of why we've been
staying about the same numbers then it's
also related to to the Staffing I think
representative Nano has a question yeah
thank you chairman Edwards uh quick
question on you said 19 people on the
weight list correct and and this is a
fluid weight list because some people
are jumping but what's the average time
uh on on your weight list so that that's
an an interesting question to answer um
so um it is very fluid so similar to
what the comant said we it isn't like
you know you take a number and you you
get first first come first serve a lot
of it also depends on the paperwork that
was mentioned so of those 19 we have um
I'd say nine right now that are we we
quote quotequote uh active but if you
put an application in today and you're
diligent about getting all your
paperwork done and in addition any
individual that has a guardian has to
get a probate court permission to come
to us so if you can get through the
court we can admit somebody in as little
as three to four months but the average
is about six months um that being said
there are some people on our wait list
that are not clinically ready um so
their application has been submitted our
second iatrist and our clinical team
will review them and say we'd like to
see them on this new medication another
month or two so it might drag out a
little bit for those types of reasons
and then similar to what the comment I
mentioned some people will also put
their applications as a placeholder
they're still doing okay at home like we
have a lot of situations where you know
somebody's being managed at home by
their elderly parents who are now in
their 80s they're planning ahead so they
put them on our wait list so that they
can start getting the paperwork and
stuff done um but the paperwork is is
very arduous it it it can easily take
three or four months to get everything
done again if that's if the family is
being very diligent so it's so it's
actually better than it looks if you
just hear the 19 number correct okay
thank
you uh any other questions on
census uh the next slide uh speaks to
our vacancy rate um I mean it basically
speaks for itself but I will highlight
that you know out of the overall
vacancies of a 37% % that's all
departments if you look us at nursing
nurses are at 51% vacancy rate Ln are at
52% vacancy rate and you know that's
again on
General very similar to the the comant
again I'm sorry I keep repeating what
she's saying but second shift is our
real challenge LNA is on second shift we
have a 66% vacancy rate um so that
that's where our biggest draw is is
trying to cover that that shift um and
we have the same shift differentials as
mentioned
previously why what what's driving the
shift do do you they negotiated with
their
Union it's all state employees union oh
it's a state same Union okay so we have
the same shift
differentials and and as she advocated
for I would love to see the lnas beyond
the same shift differential as the
nurses but um that is well it's not the
same the same percentage Maybe
that would certainly help right shift
differential is you know 40% it should
be 40% for whatever hourly wage you're
making that's what it was when I was an
hourly worker the union has negotiated a
set dollar amount right so it's not a
percentage again we um you know do
everything we can to recruit um very
similar to was I mentioned before we
advertise we go to reach out to schools
um you know we try and grow our own as
much as possible um and those kind of
things so it our remoteness does help uh
hurt us a little bit you know we we
compete with Grafton uh nursing home uh
we we trade staff back and forth every
once in a while um but we have the same
similar
challenges any other questions about
Staffing representative nalco yes thank
you chairman quick uh Bill a question
that uh our representative priest asked
uh uh previously in the last
presentation is do you have any uh
program that helps with uh I I know it's
pretty commendable on what you're doing
with nurses is is part of that tuition
payments or uh forgiveness we do not
have a mechanism to provide tuition
assistance other than um through the
department but nothing no forgiveness
programs uh we do try to do everything
we can to support that we do have a
couple of employees that are taking
nurses classes so we will adjust their
schedules so that they can uh still work
and uh attend classes is if possible we
um try and assist them doing their
clinicals with us so again they can work
while they're getting their clinical
credits uh so we try to be as creative
as we can but we do not have a mechanism
for uh tuition reimbursement so I mean
you have tremendous success and we
commented on that on the number of uh
graduate lnas and m&as uh is that
something that you're doing that can be
replicated someplace else because that
looks like a fantastic success rate um
Yes actually the veterans home used our
curricul um um you we the Comm and I um
uh have a a very good working
relationship she actually worked at Glen
GFF home for a number of years um so uh
we piggy back off of each other and and
try and use each other's creative ideas
thank
you let's talk drugs so I would expect
you to have a very high drug bill I
would assume all of your patients are
fairly heavily sedated or what or
medicated well not sedated um medicated
uh Med yes um however um we don't pay
for the medications um because they are
Medicaid um recipients um we have a
contract with a pharmacy Health direct
and they bill um Medicaid directly um so
the only thing that we pay for is any
over-the accounter medications like Tums
and Advil and things like that so it's
so you have a very small bill for
General funds to pay for yes yes yes and
thankfully because the psychotropics are
extremely expensive so okay
um what what else would you like to tell
us you've got you've got some financials
here on a on a separate sheet in your
budget briefing book is there anything
you want to draw our attention
to um in the uh the Professional Care
accounting unit that that begins on page
984 I I think one thing just to point
out there just to be consistent with the
other conversations that we have had is
there are uh 54 positions that are
unfunded there I don't know if you want
to speak to that the nurses lnas um yeah
so um in class um uh 5710 that's our
professional care so that is uh nursing
in activities and medical records uh we
had 54 positions um
unfunded um and that is 16 nurse
positions 37 LNA positions and then one
activities position um which were all
unfunded in the government So based
based on your funding level uh what's
the maximum or what's the best vacancy
rate you could come down to to maintain
the
75 well I I'm I'm I'm just looking at
this uh slide where you have your all
your vacancy rates yes and and I'm
hearing in that on page seven and then
I'm I'm hearing that there are some
unfunded positions correct so to me that
means we've built in a at least a
baseline vacancy
rate yes I would agree with that um okay
what what what's what's that Baseline
where if if we could drop the nurses and
um LNA vacancy from 50 52% to 30 even
30%
um that would um we'd be able to reduce
how much overtime we use we would
probably be able to um eliminate the
agency so to be clear on what you're
saying what I think you're saying what
I'm wanting to hear is that you have the
funding in this proposed budget so that
if you could find the people you could
hire enough of them to get down to the
30% vacancy rate uh those positions are
unfunded so so so so we've basically
inst institutionalized and built in a
permanent vacancy rate in your clinical
care of
47%
correct there's no funding available to
get you lower than
47% I I I'm asking because it's a little
incredulous but I I want I want to make
sure I'm I'm understanding sure so so
there there's there there's another
important component here that I just
want to draw your attention to so B
basically there there's over 50
positions that have been unfund within
this accounting unit um and then as as
Todd was indicating um there has been a
a utilization of agency Staffing so in
the prior in the prior year it was about
a million dollars in total and that's
that's used to uh hire additional nurses
and and others where where needed
currently we've spent about $800,000
year to date in this year and you'll see
that the contracts line on page 985
class 101 it's budgeted at15 $5,000 what
we've typically done is when we go
through the fiscal uh Department wide
transfer process is we move money from
those vacancies over um the the hope is
obviously that we're able to fill those
positions but where we haven't been able
to fill we've used that money that is
now no longer available in order to fund
that agency contract so we will we will
have
challenges I'm still looking for a
baseline that's built in because of the
way the the finances are working are are
we are we
institutionalizing what the at a 40%
vacancy rate for clinical care or if we
move the money around we could get down
to 40% we could get to 30% I'm I'm just
trying to understand how how how how
much flexibility we have to get out of
our own
way for them to be able to hire to get
their census up to get the New Hampshire
hospital patients out
quicker sure so the the department I I
mean we have the ability to move money
around the department however when we do
have a pretty significant reduction
within one area that's obviously going
to make it more difficult because if we
don't have money to post a position then
we never have a chance of hiring a
position I mean we're going to engage in
Dynamic ways that that we can but
ultimately when it's it's similar to the
back of the budget cut that we had two
years ago where we basically had to take
a couple hundred positions off offline
um I mean we'll work dynamically but but
this is going to be challenging
particularly when we've relied on some
of that vacancy funding to fund the
agency
Staffing represent Str Ian it sounds to
me like like the way this proposed
budget is put together it's not workable
to even achieve the level of results
that you've gotten this time in order to
achieve the level of results when you
have open positions you use the excess
funds from H from the staff that you
didn't hire to use contract workers and
right now you won't have any source of
fund to hire contract workers therefore
we either have to rob from some some
other part of the DHHS budget or just
not hire them which means higher uh
lower census not not um not a greater
census to reduce um the um uh your Your
Capacity um so you you know I'm just I'm
just wondering if we'd be better off uh
um you know funding more of these
positions and then having an expectation
of of some lapse in this department to
give you the flexibility you need to at
least keep up uh this level of um of
service to our community and I don't
know if if either one of you have any
comment on that or you can help me to
think about uh how we craft the budget
to help you succeed more money
one answer sure so I I I'm I'm gonna I'm
G to make this even more complicated so
what one other thing to consider is you
know if if there if there's lower census
like if if we're not able to hire and
that results in lower census then that's
going to result in lower revenue and and
so it's it's it's it's it's it's
obviously not a onetoone or a linear a
direct linear relationship but there's
certain challenges there I mean we'll as
as a department we would we would
effectively potentially need to transfer
um funds from some other program in
order to continue to sustain the
Staffing levels just because we will
have attrition at some point in time we
don't know when but um it it it will be
a
challenge represent seaworth thank you
Mr
chairman I'd like to try to ask the same
question but slightly differently and
maybe there there'll be an answer so
those 54 unfunded positions how many if
you had to guess
are they're probably unfunded because
you're not going to find the people and
how
many could you project that you might be
able to fill those if you just had the
authority to do
it that that's a great question but very
difficult to answer um as Nathan
mentioned if they're not funded I can't
even post them so then I'm not going to
fill any of them um which is going to to
affect our census and the use of of
travel nurses um you
know off the top of my head I would say
we need at least a third of those
positions to be able to eliminate the
use of overtime and agency nurses and to
get um fully up to the one the 75 where
we're CA right now and give us a
comfortable uh margin for attrition
because um you know we we do have some
turnover um somewhere in here I wrote
down the numbers we we were able to um
uh hire uh 18 staff this year but 21
left um for the same reasons that the
comment was talking about you know the
the the pay increase that we got in the
last pum was great but again that
brought us up to average um not High um
so um you know when when Grafton uh
offers a higher rate that we have staff
you know transfer back to them
so if a followup I know we've had this
conversation at the County nursing home
we've had it with
corrections and so part of the challenge
it it's the same thing you could save
money if you could hire that onethird
but in some cases the department heads
just know they're not going to get that
many people because they know how many
applications they get when they do post
and so that's kind of of those onethird
could we actually hire them or is the
real limit like what we talked about
with the veterans home that there just
aren't the people applying and that's
really that provides a practical cap on
uh I would say it's kind of a
combination um absolutely um I we' have
certainly seen an increase in the last
year um versus the four before that um I
think as the um economy struggles we do
better um because we're the state in
people see our wonderful benefits um I
mean that's one challenge that I've seen
over the last you know number of years
is um the biggest attraction used to be
retirement and and benefits younger
people don't seem to care about
retirement anymore um and the Really
younger people who you know make up a
majority of new lnas stay on their
parents Insurance until they're 26 um so
they it isn't quite the draw it used to
be U so then it comes down to what we
pay on an hourly
rate thank you
I don't see any other oh represent
wner
so the traveling nurses are are just
incorporated into the Personnel line is
that
correct so or do I see them someplace
else sure so so the the contract line on
page 95 that that that is that is low
and that the reason for that is because
we've budgeted the funds in the
positions under the the goal of being
able to hire those in the the long run
but in actuality like in this bium what
we've had to do is we've had to move
those dollars over where again last
state fiscal year we spent about a
million dollars on agency Staffing
year-to date it's about
$800,000 so far um as of as of this
morning um so so that that's been
intentional but when you look at that
contract line it's if you look at the
actual versus the budget there you
you'll you'll see the
discrepancy we pay them out of 101
I'm not seeing the contract line can you
sure it's on page
985 the accounting unit is
5710 and then it's 101 medical payments
to Providers oh oh my apologies I was
using the wrong language it's my
fault so could I follow
up so the actual expense was over a
million dollars
in
24 and now it's I mean now it's going
down to 185 it's you don't nearly have
enough money in that category right and
and and that's more of a function of of
the budgeting process because we didn't
we didn't want to abolish the positions
so we wanted to keep the money in the
positions under the goal of being able
to hire those in the long run and that's
through the department-wide transfer is
where we'll move money once we've
confirmed that we're not going to that
we haven't filled those positions in
that vacancy drag and we move that over
for those
expenses so in the fiscal year 24 the
authorized adjusted was very similar to
the 185 then we transferred money into
it to bring it up as we needed to to pay
for the the travel nurses and have we
not we haven't transferred yet for um 25
we we have transferred currently the
authorization uh the authority is
slightly less than 1.2 million in state
fiscal year 25 in that 101
line thank
you
okay represent Stringham just to be
clear if it hasn't been clear to
everybody that the this budget isn't
workable
because we fund positions from one
budget item that we didn't use from and
then we take all that money out since we
didn't use it and and instead uh we
transfer to another line item which is
the contract workers and we don't fund
that either so it's money we've actually
spent to provide the services at the
current level of care and census and
we've basically taken it out of of both
sides so in order for for this budget to
even be consistent with the current
budget it's got to be in one place or
the other uh with the flexibility to
allow the department uh to move the
funds that where they can uh best
achieve the
objectives and this is the only time
I've seen it this dramatic so so there's
there's a two-step part of my response
to that one is I'd be happy to see your
proposal uh to make it to fix it and two
i' want to hear the department respond
to
it I I I think representative Singham
has um I identifi the the challenge that
we currently have where historically
again we've we've we've funded that
contract line out of the vacancy dollars
which are not there
now
yeah and so what's your proposal
represent Stringham it sounds it sounds
like ultimately we need to come up with
more resources that aren't in the
forecast yeah we either have to fund
fund the positions or at least a portion
of the
positions uh and um uh we could do it
the same way we did the veterans homes
which is continue to fund the positions
and then plan for a lapse because
there's clearly going to be a lapse in
the veterans homes um uh or I may be
able to think of something else yeah I
keep thinking because I think the
challenge to that is if um it the fir
the opening bid on that play is that we
need to find additional resources that
we're not not seeing from um Ways and
Means and and having a lapse a greater
lapse at the end would happen but our
issue is we have to submit a a balanced
budget so there's a limbo going on
here that's why we get the big bucks I
know I know and that's why I'm going to
the the smartest guy on the committee to
say what how how do how how do we fix
this in a way that's
uh
tenable
but so so so what do you think it's your
budget it's your operation are you
comfortable with this budget can you can
you uh operate your organization for the
next two years with this
budget um as Nathan responded earlier
that is our challenge is to figure out
how to continue to have the Staffing to
keep the census at the current
level oh man I I'm I I so wish you all
could just speak
plainly said a yes or
no uh I think currently if the budget
stays exactly the way it is we might
have to look at lowering our senses all
right there I can understand that thank
you representative tki I was just going
to comment on um the governor's budget
address and her commitment to the
members of our community that are the
most vulnerable and if I had to put a
label on your clients in Glen Cliff
hospital I think they fall under that
category so um if we can find some
solution um to help I think we need to
figure that out representative priest
thank you Mr chairman
um by what amount what percentage would
you be
lower if the bu if this current
Governor's budget is approved how many
less nurses and what would your census
be so so currently so we have four units
uh currently we are not using one at all
and then a second one we have um reduce
the number of residents on it and what
we are using it for is more of our
transitional unit so even though it
could hold 75 residents we have nine and
they're the most independent um uh and
most cognitive able to be um by
themselves more so we can staff it with
one or two um staff I think currently if
if if the budget stays the way it is we
would have to look at closing that unit
and condensing down to two um so we get
economy of scale Staffing and then we
would drop to a maximum of 70 um which
means we would probably average about
68 do do you have a prioritized need
that's been organized and submitted for
to to address the Personnel issue no the
the the agency budget was prepared back
in August and the the Personnel
reductions transpired after
that you in effect have a prioritized
need that we just need to document make
sure we understand what um I I I think
we can take it back and um and and we
can we we can provide a a document to
the committee that gives a little bit
more be called a prioritized need
anymore just because of the semantics
but it would have the same effect or
purpose more of a change request at this
point yeah
okay well great great very uplifting
budget presentation so thank
you so so representative priest are your
Li us on to you thank you Mr
chairman all right um I I we meandered
here towards the end I feel like we're
come to a conclusion but I don't want to
cut you off if if you still have more
slides or more information to share with
us the the only thing I'd like to just
add is um because you were fishing
earlier for an invite to the the
veterans home yeah um and I know you've
been up to the campus and I appreciate
everybody that comes up and sees us but
the very last slide you'll see that you
know this March 22nd is our annual
sugaring off so if you guys like fresh
maple syrup on ice cream and homemade
donuts we'd love to see you
thank
you that's excellent how's the weather
going to be that
day well if if uh history says it'll be
uh freezing
rain but we're going to keep our fingers
crossed yeah all right well we we'll
thank you for coming in to conquer thank
you very much enjoy the drive
back okay so who do you want to submit
next New Hampshire hospital or Hamstead
Hospital
New Hampshire hospital will present next
um I do not have a lot to present on
Hamstead hospital as the entire budget
has been zeroed out but we can certainly
talk about that following
there oh the entire budget has been
zeroed out for yeah we can talk I can
talk about that now I can talk about it
no no it's a it's a great teaser though
okay stay tuned
that should
be what should Hamad
Hospital good morning
so we're just doing a little paperwork
you could begin if you'd like sure thank
you so for the record my name is Ellen
Le Point I'm the CEO at New Hampshire
hospital with me today is Brett Mason
he's the Chief Financial Officer at New
Hampshire hospital um and much like in
some of the other DHHS presentations so
far we do have a couple of additional
folks in the audience in case we have
some need for support in any of the
questions that you have um first off
without taking too much time cuz I know
that uh we want to be mindful of that I
just want to thank the uh chairman and
the members of the committee for all the
time that you've taken so far um as well
as the time being taken today to listen
to these budget conversations and to
really engage with us in asking um key
questions that can help uh be very
supportive so thank you for that um
you'll notice that much like the Glen
Cliff presentation ours is pretty
concise and although the work we do I I
wouldn't necessarily call the work we do
uh concise I do hope that we're able to
portray today um the necessary
information to share with you um and
cover any questions that you may have
sure so if we want to cross reference
the governor's budget what what page do
you start on do you know we'll be
starting on page
1,25 one
125 okay so if we can move to slide two
I'll just spend a brief moment on our
mission statement um to help citizens
with acute mental illness stabilize
their conditions and live their best
lives um I want to Echo some of what
you've heard today as well as in other
DHHS presentations that we take a lot of
pride in this mission statement um
there's been conversations about the
vulnerability of the population served
in the 247 facilities the same is very
much true at New Hampshire hospital um
and it it truly is our mission to
support them and help rehabilitate them
and return them to a community based
setting um also as you know New
Hampshire hospital is really one of kind
in the state there are certainly a
handful of much smaller designated
receiving facilities or drfs that make
up approximately 6 60 60 additional beds
throughout the state however New
Hampshire Hospital's capacity is 185 and
we serve the most acutely mentally ill
adults in New Hampshire in our nine
units if we can move to slide
three um again I won't spend too much
time here but um I mentioned our mission
in providing acute impatient psychiatric
care um I I did want to spend just a
moment on the admission process we do
work with various referring facilities
the the majority being um emergency
departments in hospitals Statewide we
also work with correctional facilities
for admissions and even with other
designated receiving facilities when
patients are too acute for their setting
and require a higher level of care uh a
main priority at New Hampshire hospital
is of course safety in identifying um
illnesses and treating patients and
helping them to achieve that level of St
stability in our efforts to uh
coordinate the most appropriate
placement of patients throughout the
state you've probably heard um about
Mission zero the mission zero initiative
New Hampshire hospital is a key part of
that initiative and we're really proud
of the work that that entire uh Mission
has been able to accomplish and um
looking forward to the continued work
therein um a major part of mission Euro
at New Hampshire hospital in particular
is our care Traffic Control Department
or CTC um and through the implementation
of care traffic control which just
celebrated its one-year anniversary back
in January of this year CTC has really
become the central Hub of the referrals
uh Statewide and to some extent uh
patient placement as well CTC receives
all of the state's IAS as well as other
legal statuses and refers those ieas out
to the other designated receiving
facilities based on their Collective
relationships and detailed knowledge of
capacity capabilities and established
routine meetings that New Hampshire
hospital hosts with the other designated
receiving facilities this work has
significantly enhanced the teamwork and
collaboration Statewide um as part of
the mental health system and you'll see
some subsequent slides with information
on some of the things we've been able to
accomplish under this Mission zero
initiative if we can move to slide four
you can see um some of our staffing
information um this was information that
was submitted from the agency phase so
we submitted um 699 positions for New
Hampshire hospital 13 of them being
unclassified um and I'll talk about
those in a moment um some of the further
breakdown shows that hospital
Administration staff is in
8400 8410 is primarily our operation
staff such as Environmental Services
maintenance laundry food and nutrition
Etc uh 8750 is really the bulk of our
staffing it includes unclassified
pharmacists as well as clinical staff um
which could be nurses Nurse managers
mental health workers social workers
dietitians Etc um and then just for
clarity
um accounting unit 6096 was the unit
that supported the path program that was
our Philbrook adult transitional housing
program this program remains in
operation um in the Philbrook building
currently it was stood up originally in
2022 by New Hampshire hospital in
transitioned um in the last calendar
year over to um NFI for oversight and
operations and that is a contract
through the division of Behavioral
Health under director
Fox um I did want to spend a little bit
of time um on some of our um engagement
rates and quit rates and vacancy rates
at New Hampshire hospital as you've
heard in other presentations we are
facing somewhat similar challenges as it
relates to agency utilization and
Staffing however I am really proud to
say that um the vacancy rate for
full-time staff at New Hampshire
hospital is approximately 7 % if you
were to break that down to specifically
to nurses and mental health workers
which are vital team members in
providing patient care it is a little
higher however it remains in the low um
20s and I would say though that um our
we have a really strong recruitment
initiative we have over 60 different
active initiatives to be able to recruit
staff um and approximately 64% of our
new hires in the last SE uh several
months have been through um referral of
our current staff members we also have a
really um great amount of staff who have
as um comedon mentioned um retention we
have a really high retention rate at New
Hampshire hospital it's actually um a
little bit higher than the national
retention rate which we're really proud
of so we strive really hard at focusing
both on recruitment efforts as well as
retention efforts
um if comfortable with the committee I
can move to slide five which is some of
New Hampshire hospitals key
accomplishments I did want to mention
the high security unit um that build is
in progress we did break ground as you
know we have been on target with the
construction up until the end of this
past calendar year um the uh the
construction has most recently
experienced some delays as it relates
some to some foundational testing that
needs to occur however we do hope that
that will um be appropriate and we'll be
able to pick back up here in the coming
months um we do not anticipate needing
to fund the operating budget in this
next bium so um that's a that's a small
win um I would say we may need to back
into some staffing expenses at the end
of the bium to gear up for occupancy in
the following bium however um we have
been doing taking advantage of this time
and doing a lot of operational planning
for occupying that unit um and we think
that we will be very prepared at that
time to propose um you know the the
Staffing levels that we think would be
appropriate um I do want to also spend
some time I mentioned CTC um and the
cumulative efforts of mission zero as a
result of those efforts there has been a
43% reduction in emergency department
wait times for Pat patients who require
our level of care that's pretty
significant um in most recent months
we've been able to get that weight time
to under two days um and the average
weight list has dropped from numbers in
the 30s to numbers in single digits as
recently as February 2025 and there have
been several occasions where we've been
able to hit zero adults waiting in
emergency departments throughout the
state um and as A4 mentioned New
Hampshire Hospital's full Capac capity
is
185 we recently hit that number there
has been a significant amount of effort
and focus on retaining uh returning New
Hampshire hospital to our full capacity
um early in the last calendar year we
were approximately in the high 140s to
low 150s as census um we have been able
to achieve 185 and hope to be able to
maintain that um as you know a lot of
pressure to keep those beds uh online
and to uh have the appropriate Staffing
to do
so um the next slide indicates some
additional data points as it relates to
this work um you can see on slide six uh
a drop in the average Q so that's the
number of patients who have been waiting
for a bed at New Hampshire hospital um
and you can see a slight increase in
summer months it's relatively common for
us um but overall a really great uh drop
in those
numbers and then slide seven um is the
last slide before Brett will jump into
some of the accounting unit information
um this is important context for you to
have in terms of continued support for
the mission zero efforts this slide
speaks to the importance of um folks
that are remaining at New Hampshire
hospital and some of the difficulties
we've faced in being able to trans
transition them into community- based
settings um thank you for your
acknowledgement in that um in Prior
present ations as well um at any point
in time between 2023 and um current
state we have approximately 90 to 100
individuals residing at New Hampshire
hospital hospital who would be eligible
to be discharged however due to various
reasons such as system capacity issues
limitations um housing concerns across
the state various levels of housing
availability um not just Independent
Living that um that is considerably
difficult for us we have been able to
see some relief in that and have
partnered very closely um with other
organizations and been able to see that
drop in more recent months slightly you
can see that little dip uh there at the
end um but important to Just note that
to this Committee in terms of the work
that we need to continue to do um in the
importance of the mission zero efforts
may I may I ask you a question about
slide seven here
sure okay so I think I heard you say
that that you can have a census of about
185 correct and this chart indicates
that you're often over a hundred of
people who could be
discharged so so that means you really
only have like 85 people or so that
ought to be in the New Hampshire
hospital the the rest of them are
treading water until we can find
someplace to discharge them
right is that is that a good summary of
this I think that that's a good summary
there is occasions of course that um
that population that 100 or so
population does EB and flow in terms of
their treatment needs but overall yes we
do have a significant portion of our
census who no longer needs that level of
care okay so I I know that this has been
talked about for a few years on on what
we need to do to open up capacity so you
can be discharging people could you just
give us a quick summary of what has been
tried to provide additional capacity for
you to discharge into and what has been
the holdup and having anything really
work I think it's I would say a number
of things have been tried I would say
that um as part of mission zero this is
sort of the phase of the project that we
are really moving into at this stage as
well we had a lot of focus at the
beginning on um maintaining really front
door initiatives and how we increase our
census at New Hampshire hospital and how
we make more beds available available
now we're really moving into more
backdoor focused efforts or what we
refer to as the backdoor um so I think
more focus on this to come but I would
also say that as was afor mentioned by
Todd there has been efforts to
transition folks out of glencliffe into
more community- based settings we do
have Partnerships with um other
long-term care facilities particularly
straford County who has been very
supportive in transitioning folks out of
New Hampshire hospital into that level
of care um through efforts such as under
Mission zero such as the uh landlord
incentive that has been extremely
beneficial in supporting community-based
movement of individuals uh back into
community based settings so I would say
some of those things have worked I think
the work that we still have to do is
really understanding from a Statewide
perspective what resources we need um
and there has been Tools in place to try
to gather more of that information to
really understand you know out of that
100 20 need this level of care five need
this level of care and really be pretty
concise with that that's not information
that we've really had readily available
um to the degree that I think it's
necessary to make those informed
decisions and be able to put forth
specific needs uh for
consideration represent tki thanks I'm
equally as um concerned about this
number of patients waiting for discharge
and I'm just wondering if you can give
us an idea of the um length of stay of
patients and in particular this
community that once they receive a level
of treatment and they're in a good place
how long are they stuck waiting I would
say that it definitely varies um on the
highest and we do have a handful of
folks who have been at New Hampshire
hospital for over a year generally our
average length of stay is approximately
60 days that a little bit higher than 60
days that is skewed by this population
um the population who faces less
barriers in receiving their treatment
and returning to the community tends to
have a length of stay closer to 15 to 30
days thank
you so so what percentage of these folks
really need ongoing
uh in patient care but elsewhere versus
how many of them are ready to return to
the community with some community-based
uh counseling support I think it's a
great question that's some of the work
that we're doing now to try to
understand better however I would say
that a a high portion of these
individuals do continue to need a level
of supportive care and not necessarily
in a long in a in a nursing home setting
we have seen some relief in the nursing
home settings to be able to accommodate
patients but we don't want to be
obviously transitioning folks into those
settings who don't need that level of
care generally it's folks who um and
again we're we're working on this from a
more detailed perspective but generally
it's folks who need some type of
supported living whether it be a group
home or some type of transitional
setting that assists them with a lower
level of Acuity treatment and helps be
supportive to them to return into the
community once they've uh reached those
mileston
stones but you don't have an idea of a
percentage between an inpatient and
outpatient breakdown I I don't I'd be
happy to take that back and try to do a
little bit more of an analysis for you
um again I I probably would venture to
say um over half to
60% um would require some type of
supported living out of this 100 but but
I'm sorry supportive living in an
inpatient or an outpatient outpatient so
it would probably look well it depends
on what you would consider a group home
to be I I consider that a community
based setting an outpatient setting as
opposed to an acute inpatient setting so
um a group home um environment would
support a additional level of care but
obviously not you know a 247 nursing
model yeah if we if we're providing the
shelter I I think of that as an
inpatient you know it's it's a it's a
step down certainly as a step step down
big step down but it it it's it still
seems if we're providing shelter uh it's
become a form of uh impatient but
representative so I guess when you come
back with some more information uh I
don't know if you're going to be able to
get to that in the budget cycle if it's
going to make our decision but I think
long run I we need to understand better
what the needs of this group are because
that helps us figure out you know what
priority we put on Solutions so uh
representative
priest thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you for everything you do I really
appreciate it
um with your zero mission is do they do
you have a mandate of how many days you
need to to keep the patients there
before you release them to hopefully a
community base uh
facility or is that just depending upon
um the level of treatment that's
required for each of the patients the
lad um we OB so the latter in that it's
really dependent um per specific patient
we do have patients who are there under
Court ORD so of course we have to comply
with the parameters therein if we feel
that they need a a longer length of stay
that goes beyond that court order then
we're obligated to go back to the court
to justify that um but it's very patient
dependent and um I would assume um most
of this is Medicaid um funded okay and
and they have no you have to release
these patients in 20 days or else kind
of mandates that we're finding in
private hospitals we're not getting that
kind of a mandate however we're
typically getting authorizations for 15
to 17 days so that's the amount of days
we get paid for but the patients will
stay with us could you speak closer to
the mic the people at home need to get
you closer to the mic how is this better
all right uh so typically um Medicaid
and other payers will give us an
authorization that's a certain number of
days so those are the days 15 and 17
days usually the general range yeah um
and they'll pay for okay they'll pay for
those but we're not going to we're not
going to send a patient out until we
have an appropriate place to put them
okay thank you
we ready to move on did you represent
Wallner can you tell me what your um
daily rate is sure our current daily
rate is
$1,599 okay a follow-up question um of
all of the of the close to a 100 people
who are waiting at New Hampshire
hospital but could transition to some a
different type of care would that care
be less
expensive it generally would be um I'm I
don't recall the per Dum at Glen Cliff
but as an example it's less than half of
our
rate okay I was wondering about even
though it's not in your depart not in
your department anymore but the path
program which you developed a couple of
years ago um
how what was the daily rate there when
you were able to transition people out
that's a good question I don't recall
the daily rate there but it was less
than
$1,000 so certainly less expensive than
New Hampshire hospital okay thank
you representative Stringham so just to
reemphasize you know looking at your
discharge more than half of the the
patients there are essentially being
warehoused until
um until we find a more appropriate less
expensive setting of care but as of
right now we're incurring the cost um uh
at a much higher at this higher level
roughly $1,500 a day um you know waiting
waiting for those things to show
up yes I mean they are receiving a uh a
level of treatment and support but not
necessarily um at the lever level that
is required to have them remain at New
Hampshire hospital
thank
you go ahead all right so moving on to
slide number eight and I I'd like to
just start with the the two accounting
units that are not on here because
they're they're not being funded so we
just talked about path which was
accounting unit
6096 um we took all of the funding out
of it at the beginning of this fiscal
year because we transitioned that
program to NFI North so we don't have
any uh budget requests for that one
additionally the high security unit is
accounting unit 3171 and we have no
funding in that accounting unit as
well um so accounting unit
8400 which starts on page one25 excuse
me
1026 um this is our Administration
includes our leadership Emergency
Management safety personnel um and a few
other
positions the next one is accounting
unit
8410 which is on page 102
and it includes our facility food and
nutrition supply chain Environmental
Services accounting unit 8750 is where
the bulk of our clinical staff are
nurses mental health workers social
workers it's also the accounting unit
that we use to pay the contract for
Dartmouth Hitchcock for our physicians
and other
providers on on um on
Administration do do we do we have any
lingering big bills still to upgrade
facility
security I know I know the the the foyer
has been completely paid for and
renovated at least I think that's true
do throughout the facility are there
other safety requirements that we're
aware of that are in this budget uh no
not at this point in time I mean we do
have some fire safety work ahead of us
the foyer Lobby renovation actually is
going to be starting in the next uh 30
days um but in terms of of funding um no
major asks at this stage and we do have
um units in need of renovation but are
not in a place or desire to take beds
offline to do so um so perhaps at a
future State thank you and while it's
not a project uh we uh a result of the
findings from our um November
2023 um issue was that we needed uh more
on-site security so we have we're
working on Contracting with a security
firm and that's included our say that
phrase again for Onsite what what did
you just say what's the What's the
phrase you use for Onsite onsite
security oh you need on-site security so
you of all the employees that you
currently have none of them are
specialized in security duties right so
currently we contract with the
Department of Safety and we have S so
police that are
are security for the entire campus the
seate office complex so so you imagine
having to beef up that security
relationship right and is that in the
budget yes yes oh okay all
right
okay right so on slide number nine I
have our vacancy rates that go across
our accounting units and I have them
Broken Out by full-time and
part-time um as Ellen noted we're at
around 15 to 17% vacancy rate for our
full-time position right now which is a
significant decrease from even just
about 2 years ago where we were over
23% slide number 10 I just have listed a
couple of our more expensive uh it
system so obviously our electronic uh
medical record which is is called Avatar
we have our pixus medication dispensing
system which our Pharmacy uses to make
sure our patients get the right doses at
the right time and then the inovalon
electronic claims management systems
helps us uh bill I I may be getting you
confused with a a historical fo footnote
from Hamstead but it wasn't that long
ago that did how long have you had an
electronic medical record system years
yes oh okay so it's Hamstead that didn't
have one correct that's right
yes all right and then our last slide we
just talk a bit more about the high
security units so in our agency budget
we had had anticipated that perhaps we
would be able to um fully staff the
facility in fiscal year 27 we've had a
few delays in the construction and we
expect the building to be completed in
fiscal year 27 um but we don't have a a
great date at this time as to when it
will be completed um so the ask really
would be for the sfy 26 that are in here
to be available in 27 really for basic
building maintenance items um for once
the facility is constructed and vacated
by the construction company so so again
I need to get you closer to the
microphone I'm cuz it's really me that's
deaf I was just blaming it on the people
at home but uh so so what happens if you
don't get this what how how do you work
around your security
requirement we don't really have a
security requirement for this facility
in this bium because we're not
anticipating having it open to patients
in this by this coming by anym yeah uh
the only expense that we do anticipate
incurring are basic utilities expenses
things that you have to just keep up for
a vacant building right I I I I think
I'm talking about page 11 are you yes
the high security unit yes so I I think
that the the dollars that are in there
for fiscal year 27 we can remove those
and the amounts that are in there for
fiscal 26 we would like to move to
fiscal 27 okay those are just for basic
utilities thanks thank you uh
representative seaworth did you have
have a question could you also refer to
where this what the page and the
governor's budget it's not in the
governor's budget it's not in there at
all is so where would it go if you you
requested we put it in where would we be
putting it so the accounting unit exists
it's accounting unit 3171 3171 and it it
was part of our agency request um but
then not funded by the
governor is that and and maybe does that
accounting unit exist somewhere in this
book or is
that so the BEC because there's no
history there because it's brand new um
that doesn't that that won't print to
show a record because otherwise it would
just show 0000000000 across everything
there and and I think that's the reason
why you're not seeing it there but as as
Brett indicated it it does exist um we
just don't have money in the next panium
for it thank you representative
Stringham so on page 1038 you have
699 uh uh positions of which 686 are
permanent uh are any of those position
now unfunded in the final
budget yes uh we have 109 full-time
positions that are unfunded in the
governor's
budget so uh how will you operate
without being able to go out and add
advertise and promote for those
positions um we at New Hampshire
hospital we are utilizing agency staff
however it always is our main goal um to
have state staff um working very closely
with the department and leadership in
terms of prioritizing our Direct Care
needs to maintain operations we do feel
with our current level of Staffing and
the utilization of the agency Staffing
that we will be able to maintain census
um in terms of positions turning over we
feel like there is a good plan in place
to be able to rehire to fill those
vacant positions um however as has been
afar mentioned um it will be challenging
um in terms of uh how we prioritize
positions and how we fill them going
forward is there enough budget in the
agency Staffing lines where that fits in
to fill um the request given given that
you're going to have uh um less number
of
positions the amount of agency Staffing
in the budget is more or less continuing
our current levels which the governor's
budget
is more or less at our current vacancy
rate it matches what we're currently at
okay so your your current budget calls
for um about 20 million more in total if
I'm I'm again on page 1038
Mone on page 1038 um uh about about 20%
higher than actuals in
2024 uh about 118 million in 26 and 121
million in fiscal year
2027 where would you say those main
increases are coming from they're almost
entirely from Personnel thank you
representative n Al yeah thank you uh
chairman Edwards I quick question it's
probably because I'm a little slow and
new at this on page 11 are there headers
missing there on above those numbers or
yes thank you I I suppose we should have
put FY 26 and 27 on the left side on 26
and the right side
27 okay thank
you representative
walner so where where do I find in where
do I find the agency staff that
you keep what lines in the budget agency
staff would be in accounting unit
8750 and
in
102 contracts for program
Services that's page one
z30 one
Z and just a a note in the fy2 adjusted
off it says 16.5 million um there's 's
an error in the calculation there it's
actually a little over 20 million
because that number does not include our
current agency Staffing
contract it's corrected in the S
SOA oh it's line 102
correct thank
you all right I I don't see any other
questions and you look like you're at
the end do do you have a wrap
up no other than to say thank you for
your time sure um well thank you uh Mr
White or Dr Hannah are you coming up too
no um I I think I I remember the
punchline on this we contracted Hamstead
Hospital over to Dartmouth and that gets
us out of the cost accounting business
and so that's why you zeroed out our
budget but don't we have a revenue line
or is that completely wholly independent
and and no longer having any requirement
for us to have visibility we've
contracted we're getting some money what
what what are we doing there sure
so I is it okay if I just give a little
bit of the history just for everyone's
awareness just because it is a it's it's
a it's a it's a several years story it's
like the fourth major return in the in
the in the path so yes it might be so uh
uh on June 8th 2022 the state purchased
Hamstead Hospital from Hamstead Outlook
LLC um at that time the department
initially entered into a soul Source
contract um with a provider where
whereby they provided most all the
clinical staff the Physicians uh social
workers and the state established
administrative support rool relative to
finance as well as key executive
leadership positions um after 2 years uh
the state transitioned um into a
contract with with Dartmouth Mary
Hitchcock Memorial Hospital whereby they
were providing primarily The Physician
level positions and then the state
transferred a little over 165 positions
to the state um that that transpired in
uh June 30th of
2025 4 four 2024 thank you Marissa sorry
time flies um of 2024 and in December on
December 18th the governor executive
Council approved a a package of
contracts whereby the department entered
into a lease agreement with Mary
Hitchcock Memorial Hospital whereby Mary
Hitchcock Memorial Hospital would run
and operate
the facility there were a couple other
agreements as well there was a joint
operating committee agreement that
allows the department to continue to
have
um essentially Sway and and um Authority
as dictated by the agreement relative to
the oversight and strategic direction of
the activity of the hospitals there was
also a purchase acquisition uh that
provided I think about
$600,000 um for the whereby we sold uh
some of the uh equipment the furniture
that was on site at the hospital and
then there was also transition Services
agreement where we would continue to uh
to to continue State contracts to
support Dartmouth Hitchcock and they
agreed to pay us an administrative fee
while they transition with that
ownership and the ownership officially
took place on February 3rd that
transition Services agreement continues
uh for up up to a year but you know
we're work we're working with uh Mary
Hitchcock on a daily basis to make those
determinations and roll them off so if
you turn to page
1,62 of the governor's operating
budget you will see that Hamstead
Hospital operations has been zeroed out
in state fiscal years 26 and
27 what we were looking at annually um
based on some of the historical trends
that we were seeing with the revenue
that we were bringing in was the
potential need for up to $20 million of
General funds each year um because the
state no longer has positions there and
we no longer have um any any direct
expenses as Mary Hitchcock is now
Leasing and operating the facility um
there's no need for a budget here the
original lease agreement that I did
mention earlier that does provide for
Revenue to come to the
state however um there there is a
provision within that lease agreement
that specifies and and this is unique
I've I I've never seen an agreement
quite like this so we were looking for a
unique solution and the key provision
there is that the state is responsible
for up to $3 million of capital
Investments but th those dollars M there
must be a match on the part of Mary
hitch Co so if they spend a dollar the
state spends a dollar up to $3 million
so it's it's basically a
50/50 uh agreement whereby we will
concurrently invest money into that um
there is currently Senate Bill
118 that establishes a a Hamstead
Hospital Residential Treatment Facility
capital investment fund and the way that
that bill currently reads is that the
lease Revenue which which which is
approximately $1.3 million each year
will be deposited for the next biennium
into that accounting unit so that we
have that those dollars available and
ready to go and it's up to a maximum
amount of 3 million so we won't see the
the tenative uh plan or hope is that we
won't necessarily see that Revenue in
our budget this year because we need to
make sure that we have those dollars
immediately available and If and and if
they're not appr orated to us then we
may not be able to meet the terms of the
lease again it's it's a fairly unique
agreement the Attorney General's office
was involved in that um and Advising and
Advising us there but what we will see
in the bium um the subsequent banum is
we will probably see about $2.6 million
in total revenue um over the over the
entire bayum going forward and the lease
agreement is good for seven years seven
years with the option to renew uh for a
total of up to 20 years in in totality
so in the long run from a purely
Financial
perspective we we will see a net benefit
to the state in lie of the potential $20
million of General funds that we were
looking at for the next bium each
year but that it sounded like you said
the net Financial
benefit is that it would get plowed back
in into an account reserved for Capital
Improvements that we're obligated to
perform so so that little side account
is adds nothing to the the state's
ability other than to meet Our
obligation that money doesn't go
anywhere else yes and and that that
would be temporary um that that would
not be long run the the intent there is
to make sure that we meet that we have
money available for that $3 million
obligation and once that SA ified then
in future years that Revenue would be
available to the state and and where
would that Revenue go would that be just
into the general treasury would that go
into like an a Commissioner's Office
account have you thought that far down
um I've thought about it but I don't
necessarily think at this point in time
we've made a final decision as to where
we want to budget that I'm assuming
probably somewhere in the office of the
commissioner may be appropriate so
there's clear transparency around those
those dollars sure I'm I'm looking at
1063 are there still positions listed
there that shouldn't be down at the
bottom for Hamstead yes so today those
positions still technically exist um
they're they're not funded currently
though okay out of the Hamstead budget
okay so so the way I I was used to
Manpower accounting was these these are
like units of resource and you could
pick them up out of these accounts and
move them into other accounts if you
wanted to does the state let you do that
is that part of the state process that
was part of the federal process um So
currently they still show up in our
total FTE count yeah um and during the
transition uh when when Dartmouth was uh
when we were working with them to to
finalize the deal um the individuals
that were that were in those filled
positions we had we gave them the
opportunity to transfer to another
location within the department a number
of them transferred more of them uh
moved over to the employee of Mary
Hitchcock sure so that's a faces versus
places thing the faces moved to a
different employer but we kept the
spaces yes okay um all right so so my my
concern here now is uh talk us through
and I'm going to keep this short because
I realize we're into our lunch but if we
finish this then we can break for the
day so I'm driving on a little bit
longer um
the vision at one point uh was that
Hamstead hospital and the new YDC would
have a symbiotic relationship to the
point where they could share resources
back and forth the their the logistics
Services plus there are Manpower
services that were going to become
sharable would does this new contract
completely change that
Vision I think the vision remains the
same the way since we don't have all of
the shared services fully fleshed out
yet um Dartmouth Health expressed full
willingness and there's a there's a um
sentence in the lease I don't have it in
front of me that commits them to uh
working in good faith but we imp
particular focused on the um culinary
Services since we aren't building a
kitchen at the new YDC so that was
stated explicitly but other shared
services be it you know nighttime
nursing or education or whatnot were um
were left open with a good faith
commitment to working those in as
contract amendments later so we're going
to be moving food three times a day or
something maybe four times for a
midnight feeding so do we have a Cuisine
Corridor your former culture Corridor is
now the cuisine keep renaming it till we
fund it yeah I mean I think that's those
are the conversations that we're having
right now I think as you know additional
arpa funds were um that didn't uh move
forward with the solution Health build
and londonerry were reallocated um in
part towards several of the ad
alternates and so we're now working with
our construction and architect firm
through DPW as well as with the
governor's office to sort those out and
make sure that we have the right
selections um realizing we have a lot of
desires including space for the kids to
play Outdoors safely and um you know the
the proper interior features but
needless to say your advocacy for the
culture culinary Corridor remains a
priority for us as well okay so so I'm
allowed to keep hope alive yes okay okay
very good are are there are there
questions here representa elvano yeah
thank you chairman uh Mr White I a quick
question on the lease agreement we U we
it's multiple years and extend
extendable I'm assuming that there's
some escalation in the I mean we you
were quoting a fixed number but I'm
assuming they escalation causes in there
that would cause that that number to
increase over time the the the rent
amount yes yes it it does increase uh by
several percentage Points each year
yep okay so so when you're you're
talking about the you know 1.3 per year
and the 2.7 that would actually be a
bigger number uh slightly I was rounding
so the first Year's less than 1.3
million but but it it it it would be
slightly more over time okay thank you
I'm not seeing any more questions at
this point um do you have
any additional words of thought on this
subject or anything you've heard is no I
just think it's going well and we're
glad to be able to at a in a tough
Revenue time um to be able to provide
excellent service at the Quality we
expect without it being um an additional
um expense for the state so so I think
if I summarize everything I've heard
today the the the biggest thing I'm
concerned about is um making sure that
we have adequate Staffing levels at
glencliffe to keep their census at a
particular level and keep them able to
stay in the game for being a discharge
location for the New Hampshire
hospital um that that that was my
takeaway what what what how do you react
to that is that a legitimate concern or
or sure yeah I I I mean I think
when we think about the Department of
Health and Human Services budget we have
very unique and very complex and very
diverse uh array of business so if we're
talking about Medicaid there's $1.3
billion for the Medicaid Program but the
actual division has 34 people in it
versus if we look at New Hampshire
hospital in glencliffe which is almost
exclusively not exclusively but a very
high percentage is Personnel so person
are are critical for the operations
there and then because of the way that
we have budgeted at Glen Cliffe with the
goal of hiring those positions we we
have always used those vacancy dollars
to fund the agency staff to fill the
gaps um so it again it's it it's a
challenge um that we we certainly
recognize and we appreciate the
committee's consideration looking at
that okay so represent Stringham so um
uh you know we talked about the Glen
Cliff situation and um it's kind of uh
maybe peeled back uh a little bit what's
going on and you just mentioned now um
uh the practice of using unfilled
positions to fill funding gaps that
emerge during the incredibly complex
period of time of the two-year budget
cycle uh as you go on how much um other
areas will you do you see in at M
perhaps in adequate buffer to fill
temporary position funding gaps or other
things uh that you know may may not be
as obvious as the Glen Cliffe one is to
us so what what we've tried to what
we've tried to do in in this budget is
when we look at our department-wide
transfers that's the point at which we
essentially identify the gap between
what we budgeted and what you know what
the plan was and what what happened and
so if you think back to some of the
early presentations where we had the
little bubbles where it's like here's
your budget here's your actual here's
your cost allocation you know that's the
actual experience so we've tried to
address those areas um yesterday we
talked about dtss where we saw Nursing
Facility expenses um exceed the budgeted
amounts and we've tried to account for
that within the budget um during DCF you
know we we looked at what are the res
costs that we're seeing and we put a PN
and that was partially funded so far so
we tried to account for that looking at
the syc budget um you know that was
based on a closing budget for the
current bium so that was well below and
we had to move $3.5 Million last year
for that so we've tried to um actively
identify those other gap areas and and
and address those through the agency
budget um to
date okay thank you uh kind of my other
comment uh Mr Speaker is that um not yet
not yet not a speaker
uh Mr chairman Mr chairman uh is that um
you know I I think I think the
presentations we've heard today I think
the opportunity to make our systems more
efficient is to rely more on labor and
less on contract workers and uh both
Glen Cliffe and New Hampshire hospital
by removing um and unfund positions that
they would need to move in that
direction will be uh uh virtually
impossible for them so um what what
we'll do is uh in Glen Cliff's case
without changes will probably send it
into a death spiral in New Hampshire
hospitals I think will will put make it
more of um you know less efficient uh
and less movement away from contract
workers uh towards um towards uh
full-time staff uh you know that would
lead to a better bottom line greater
service for our for our for those in
needs so I would say that's a brilliant
observation and that probably everyone
that's looked at government level
recruiting of Health Care
Workforce agrees with you I think the
problem with counties with the state is
that uh since co co exacerbated it and
where we had to rely on uh on prum's
attempt
nursing and we just haven't figured out
how to get back to preco labor levels
and and my sense is that um that the
state can do something about it but that
the solutions are going to have to be
largely local the workforce challenges
at glencliffe are different than the
workforce challenges at New Hampshire
hospital and so each of those leadership
teams may end up with their own solution
to move us from um relying so much on
contracts to be able to rely
increasingly on our own employees and
and I I don't I'm not smart enough to
know what each of those should do I am
receptive enough to hear concrete
proposals uh and to see what we might be
able to do to to support a local
initiative and I appreciate appreciate
that and I think that's the right
direction uh is the budget as structured
may not give them enough flexibility to
do that and perhaps without dramatically
changing the budget up or down in either
way we can do that in this
process okay and and again I I I don't
feel competent to change the budget in
the absence of a local proposal to say
this is what we would do and this is how
we would do it and this is the impact on
why the budget should look a little
different I I think I think I would I
need to see a local proposal before I
have any clue its impact on how we've
how they've spent a year putting the
budget
together representative priest uh thank
you Mr chairman and and this question is
directly to you Nate and to um the
deputy and to too
um could we also look into whether or
not we can have a statutory language
request like the
veterans um department is requesting for
other departments who are facing nursing
challenges and have in statute that the
state will do a college tuition
forgiveness for a length of stage year
years at that
particular um
division 5 years 10 years I don't know
but you know make it so that we can
attract nurses they can get their
tuition paid
for and um work in these
facilities I I don't know if it's
possible but I wanted to throw it out so
so just to do a slightly modified
version of what you just asked for I
I I I I would like to see something like
that as well I would refer to it as a a
local plan and I wouldn't want to tie
their hands by saying the solution shall
include a student loan rep playment
repayment program I think I think the
other day we laid out a couple of
different alternatives on how to do that
we could do a a relocation reimbursement
uh uh we could do something to um uh
support spous employment I I and while
the loan rep payment program may be part
of a solution I just don't want to make
it sound like that's the only solution
to our Workforce problems I want people
to think more
broadly chairman Edwards um there is
currently a statute that exists it's RSA
943 uh bi- a and it it allows New
Hampshire hosital hospital and Glen
Cliff home to establish Recruitment and
Retention programs yes sir one of the
challenges there is that a you need to
have money for it B in order to get that
approved we need approval from the
Department of administrative Services
The Joint op uh The Joint Committee on
employee classification and compensation
as well as the governor and executive
counsel um so from a from a dynamic
perspective there's certainly a long
line of approvals that we have to go
through and it could fail at any point
in time and then the second that of
course is funding and it's difficult I
think it's difficult to justify a
retention program when you don't
necessarily um have staff and that's
obviously a balance and that's a
strategic judgment call but but those
are just some of the challenges but
there is something that does exist
today it doesn't sound very
Nimble it is not Nimble not
Nimble um all right um final words of
wisdom any more questions from the
committee
um is there anyone in the audience that
had come here wanting to speak Miss
Rosenberg that would like an opportunity
to speak okay come on up is there anyone
else in the audience I should be
anticipating now remember we started
lunch at
noon I know I'm I'm starving too yeah so
I'm Karen Rosenberg I'm the policy
director at the disability rights Center
um thank you for indulging me during
your LUN Lun hour but I'm hoping you're
going to get to leave after you're done
here and eat um so the reason I wanted
to raise a make a few comments here is
that um there was a reference to the
Community Mental Health agreement and so
as you may know my office brought the
lawsuit along with others representing a
class of individuals who had been um
warehoused at places like New Hampshire
hospital and glencliffe and I think we
brought the lawsuit in around 2010 going
I guess and eventually um after the
federal district court certified a class
um the parties were able to settle um
the lawsuit um actually by that time the
US Department of Justice had also
intervened in the case and so we ended
up with what were all what we all call
the CMHA or Community Mental Health
agreement and I believe that was entered
in around
2014 and the expectation the the purpose
of the lawsuit was to address this the
warehousing of people it was right the
agreement was in I believe February of
2014 um and the expectation at that time
was that um there would be a b a lot of
different services and interventions put
into place that would re reduce the
Reliance on institutional settings there
was nothing in the agreement that um
specified like number of beds or any
that you know that would be available at
these institutions instead the agreement
established some programs that um the
state had already started investing in
like mobile crisis and also um required
um an investment in services like a sort
of community treatment known as act um
supported housing supported employment
and there were some Provisions around
Glen Cliff home and how to move people
out of Glencliff home who are ready to
move out into community- based settings
and everyone hoped that we would be all
done with that by now we're not done
with that by now it the state is not
reached compliance and instead um
there's been some backsliding frankly um
we've got more people now at New
Hampshire hospital than were at New
Hampshire hospital I believe when we
filed the lawsuit so my when you're you
know I'm hearing the testimony and when
I'm thinking about takeaways one of the
takeaways for me is that we've got more
than a hundred people at New Hampshire
hospital on a daily basis who are ready
for discharge and are not appropriately
placed there and these are people who
might be able may have lost their jobs
because they've been absent for so long
and could return to work um people who
are I mean it's really about the patient
care from our perspective but it's also
costing the state $1,600 a day for each
of these people who would really
shouldn't be there similarly our office
believes that there's people at Glen
Cliff home who don't believe who don't
belong there um the CMHA was amended um
in 20
23 to address um discharge issues from
Glen Cliffe um and so one of the results
of that um amendment is that the state
um issued an RFP as was mentioned to
establish um 20 Community beds for
people who are at glencliffe or at risk
of entering glencliffe who would be
appropriate for discharge so I don't
have the up-to-date numbers but a
question might be how many of those are
online and how many are still are
available and how many people at
glencliffe are also ready to transition
to less restrictive
settings um like I said I don't have the
up-to-date numbers on that but it seems
to me that um the in you know when we're
looking at how to invest our state our
general funds which I know are extremely
precious right now we might want to
consider um the what what are the
options and what options might we want
to invest in
so the fact that you know you might wait
a long time to have to get begin getting
services at community at a community
based Mental Health Center is
problematic um we need people to be able
to have smooth transitions to intense
community- Based Services if that's what
they need um because we don't really
want them in really restrictive settings
and Glen Cliff remember it is for people
who have a combination of mental health
issues and also have a nursing home
level of care need so it's really not
always an it's probably not generally an
appropriate discharge place for people
from New Hampshire hospital unless they
also need that level of nursing home
care so it's it's just another it's
another wrinkle it's another challenge
but I think we need to try to focus on
when we have very fleeting dollars small
dollars how can we make sure that our
community mental health system is
appropriately funded um so that we're
not spending all this money to house
people inappropriately in a really
restrictive setting anyway thank you for
indulging me when you're all starving
will you take a question of course do
you have a plan or a
proposal i g I gave you my broad brush
um you know think about the investment
in Community Based Services for think
talk to our community based Mental
Health Centers what the services are
that they're providing encourage the
state to that's not not has that not
happened well I think it needs to happen
to a I think there's some of that
happening I think they're the ones who
know what they need to implement the
Community Mental Health agreement um but
you know like I said there are services
that people need that I think could be
provided through their um
programs um and I don't know that and
what do they need to increase their
capacity to do that that's the question
for for the state and for them
yeah I don't know that we have them come
to our any of our hearings since we
don't fund them directly I don't know
that they're in our budget at all so
therefore we're not talking with them
this committee right there's no I
understand that there's a pass through
from the Department that goes to the
Community Mental Health Centers um and I
and I realize that there's I think
there's directed payments that for about
$5 million for each of the next two
years that would that's in the
governor's budget I don't is that enough
I don't to do what they need to do to
make sure that everyone who needs to
have act screening for example gets it
and and needs those really intensive
Community Based Services is able to get
it are the reimbursement rates for those
Services high enough so that they can
retain the staff to provide the services
I I mean we're we're not if we're seeing
so many people who can't be discharged I
would say I would suggest all right
there's a
problem representative priest thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for being here
and for everything you do um do you know
whether or not there a Coordinating
Board that brings in organizations like
you the community health
boards um Glen Cliff the New Hampshire
hospital and say okay how many patients
do you have to be discharged what do we
have in the community base that can
facilitate them or are they or are they
on their own and there's no discussion
going on over writing discussion well I
think there is the I think you heard
about the I forget what they call it the
care trans the you know the the
Coordinating Committee that the
department has set up for people you
know who are you know entering the
mental health system the care care
traffic control yes um we're not part of
that um and I don't know that it would
be appropriate for us to be part of that
actually um what we're part of is you
know we we are in communication with the
Department about compliance with the
settlement agreement but you know and
that's something that our office F you
know follows closely because of this
agreement and the litigation but um
we're not part of that kind of committee
and like I said I don't know that it
would be appropriate for us to
be do you attend those meetings or are
you in traffic no care traffic control
no okay and so it's called the care
trafficking control okay that was you
probably know the answer better than I
do I think that's what they call it is
the care traffic control it's when
people come into the system and they're
looking at what you know where they need
to be placed and they addressed all the
present hospitals I I you know what
since I'm not on that committee I think
it would be better you should ask the
department about that okay thank
you did you have a question represent
Wallner no no okay all right thank you
for your remarks thank you I'm glad they
still let you in the building after
successfully suing
us well shouldn't you have a different
color badge a different color B well you
know we can talk I don't know if you
want to legislate that you've got enough
you know fish on it's always it's always
a pleasure talking to you uh
thanks
um and I think representative Mooney
wants to draw our attention to something
she's she's drawn at least uh one line
between two dots go go ahead thank you
Mr chairman so to representative
priest's question that care traffic
control it's uh further talked about on
page five of the New Hampshire hospital
coloring
book okay thank
you and and then you have a second
thing what uh is it is it for the good
of the committee or is it for the public
uh for everybody oh
okay so I think we've heard from
everyone in the audience M Mr Ripple I
like ending with you we're we're going
to get together at 10:00 tomorrow to do
the P dab yes I've been asked how long
that is uh I think that should take
based on what I know of what we need to
talk about I think we can nail that in
in an hour oh my uh I know Mr White's
got conflicting things so um so so I'll
try to keep that one pretty short
um and then do are we meeting tomorrow
afternoon as well yeah oh yeah oh yeah
it's a little public thing
right yes yeah 2 o' to what two in the
morning I think something like that
probably yeah bring your bring your
sleeping bags representative priest you
have your light on do you have a oh
thank you very much okay um so you don't
have anything else for us but you're but
you're going to get um a um a calendar
into for Monday with the three bills so
so yes so Janet has already sent out
that notice and it will be in this
week's House calendar okay great uh
representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman so I don't want to lose sight
of and I want to bring your attention to
House Bill
547 this has been the topic of quite a
bit of discussion so far and I can just
imagine it'll come into our work
sessions that's relative to County
reimbursement of funds now I noticed
that was on the consent calendar last
week that's a whole another discussion
passed on a Voice
vote pretty substantial fiscal note 25
so I'm just curious does that come to
division three or has that been
reassigned or not a signed yet so
that I really hate saying this because I
it's not firm but I I think we probably
have to be looking at 200 to $250
million
yeah and I'm not happy about it I'd much
rather be doing out an extra $250
million but uh that's not what's going
to happen this year does that answer
your question sufficiently for
now yes that ansers answers it and when
is work going to start on that
process well this is the really hard
part to say I I have imagined that um uh
representative tersi has been organizing
some discussions with
with four NS of the committee or 47s
whatever the right fraction is to figure
out what how you guys would want to
respond and and I I know that I've been
having meetings with the Republican side
to talk about how we want to respond you
you C you can
imagine um you know the pressure we're
feeling to do this well and do it
responsibly because so many lives are
affected and we I think we're having an
internal conversation ourselves for now
to just figure out what we what we think
right looks like before
we expose more to the public but there
will be a public phase there'll be there
will at least is a minimum there will at
least be a period where we bring forward
sort of the Republican proposal to hit
whatever final number we're supposed to
hit we'll go over it we'll give everyone
on the committee some soak time to look
at it and then we'll have a second
meeting and in that second meeting it'll
be like an exec session where we can
debate some of the line items and we'll
end up voting on what our recommendation
to the finance committee is and if you
and if you guys were doing something
similar we we we could similarly
included in a public
discussion so do you see that happening
at the end of next week I I don't know
after we look at the calendar we're
running out of we're running out of time
since you invoked my name if I might no
you had your light on I I just
recognized the brightness of your
light um we did receive a number of um
notices of work sessions coming I guess
obviously we can't before the public
hearing dig in too much but to know that
we're going to I assume hit the ground
running next Monday on this work would
be helpful I guess I just want to
clarify what you just said which is
there would be a presentation from your
side we would then reflect on it and
come back and vote on it which doesn't
seem to be the process we've used in
previous bium I don't know is it so much
different yeah I I I mean I I I've had
people tell me who who served on the
committee uh back when they were in the
minority and basically it was a take it
or leave it well that's what it just
sounded like it would be Mr chairman uh
no I I'm I'm going to I'm going to share
it and tell you what our thoughts are
and we'll have an open public talk and
every the world will see what we're
thinking and why we're thinking it so if
I may yeah if we could have those
conversations early on so that it's not
the last day before we have to move the
budget so that the public is aware of
what's happening and is going to see
where we're going to cut $200 to $250
million that's I'm concerned about
transparency I so am I
great I always have been always will be
it's almost my middle
name um but uh so we have to make sure
that we we're going to have to be
finished by the day that we're supposed
to be finished and uh and we have to
back off from there to use available
time so I don't I don't have a proposal
on our calendar
yet but the methodology is at least a
two-step process at least a two-step
process last last time I remember we
started with the idea we'd do a two-step
and it end up being three-step so so I I
do I do think it's
flexible and I do think we can
anticipate that there's going to be a
significant amount of
disagreement so um we need to make sure
that that the all the disagreements get
an opportunity to be
aired that's all I was asking for I I
think it's a fair request thank you very
much anyone else do you have you have
you want to go through notices yes so
thank you Mr chairman so yes as we've
been sitting here in committee this
morning for division three notices have
come from our assistant and they are
Monday March 17th that is to work on the
bills that were mentioned earlier by Mr
Ripple then March 18th March 19th March
24th are just publicized as work
sessions starting at 10:00 a.m. so I
just wanted to put that out there as
those notices have come out as we've
been seated here so they're nondescript
reservations of dates and times that we
can just plug in when we're going to
talk about um hb2 two
hp1s um and get at least two bites at
the Apple we we have we have room based
on the notices that have already been
published go ahead that was a question
yes the answer is yes and I see another
notice has come out and that is for
March 25th also for 10:00 a.m. work
session okay so so what m m Mr Ripple
what what is the final day that division
3 can vote out a recommendation to the
full finance committee when is when is
the full finance committee planning to
get together do you know
uh I need to check on the date that the
full finance committee uh will be
meeting I don't think that's been
scheduled yet I had been hoping that the
division and I know the other divisions
have been relying on this as well would
be finished
by I think the if the 26th is a
Wednesday sorry let me just take a look
at the calendar
here yeah would be finished by March
26th and if necessary Friday the 28th so
yes I did ask Janet to uh schedule the
following Monday Tuesday and Wednesday
of each of the next two weeks as generic
budget work sessions with the exception
of the bills on Monday um I was not
necessarily assuming that there would be
a proposal first thing on Tuesday
morning but I wanted to have the date
reserved for Budget work so I know
Tuesday afternoon for example the
department will be coming back for a
discussion of contracts so some of that
time will be devoted to follow-up
information all
right when when when is crossover April
10 so the house has to vote its position
sometime before that
obviously that when we vote on the 10
the vote in Full House will be on April
10th so I presume the full Finance needs
to have the budget leave our possession
the previous Thursday at the latest
which is the 3rd of April okay which
means if I'm doing my math correctly
this division needs to be um done with
our work by the previous end of week to
have things tied up right which is the
26 which is the 26 28th depending on
that house session dat I I want us to
aim at the 26th and only use the 28th as
a break glass in case we we just need to
do more my only question to that is I
heard a uh hold on that for a session
day am I making that up or am I
confusing my weeks 26th and 27th as
potential house session
yeah
yeah I hadn't heard the 26th but in that
case possibly uh Friday the 28th would
be the last day the division could work
oh
okay all right so we'll keep tightening
that up but that's the that's the broad
sweep
any other questions issues just I go
ahead repr thank you Mr chairman I can
trace that where we heard that on the
26th it's actually in the speaker's
message in the calendar he says there is
also a possibility that the house will
need to meet on Wednesday March
26th
okay uh um I think I think we're done
and so I'm going to adjourn today's
session of division three